welcome to an ALT shift X live stream
today we're talking about House of the
Dragon episode 3 and I gotta say crabs
in the chat for our boy kragas crab
feeder dead in one episode if you were
expecting Kruger's crab feeder the
freaky guy with the mask if you were
expecting him to be a ongoing villain
throughout the season uh sorry to
disappoint you but Daemon has slew the
crab feeder
and I love daemon's reasons for it like
the thing that spurred Daemon to go on
this like near suicide mission of like
single-handedly going and fighting the
triaki men himself to go after the crab
feeder the thing that spurred Daemon to
go and kill the crab is that his brother
viserys sent a message saying hey I'm
gonna send you Aid
and Daemon was so angry that viserys was
sending his army to help Daemon that
Daemon like beat a messenger with his
own helmet he was Furious that his
brother was helping him
and I think the reason for that is that
Daemon wants to do it himself
like like an impetuous younger brother
he refuses help because he wants to
prove his independent strength and he
wants to you know win glory to his name
personally if he lets his big brother
come and handle the problem for him his
pride would be wounded
and Daemon did this not only in like a
suicidally risky way but he did it in a
dishonorable way Daemon came to the crab
feeder with a white flag he came under a
peace banner and yet he betrayed the men
who came to accept his surrender and
attacked them instead which is what is
called a dick move
um if if you don't follow those
conventions of War if you don't respect
a peace Banner uh Wars can become more
violent than they otherwise would so
it's a pretty horrible thing to do
um and
I enjoyed that they didn't show like an
epic Jewel between Daemon and the crab
feeder we just saw Daemon carrying the
crab feeder's carcass after he was done
with him which which I liked because it
we didn't need to see the fight because
we know Daemon would win Daemon has a
Valyrian steel sword Dark sister the
crab feeder is a disease riddled uh
person who does not look like he could
put up much of a fight I enjoy crab
feeder as like you know he seems more of
like a leader who sort of skulks in the
shadows and maybe he's like The
Mastermind and you know he creates fear
by nailing people to the beach but maybe
crab feeder himself is not much of a
fighter
yeah I can respect that thanks for the
Super Chat from Kate who says can the uh
Valerie valerion children ride dragons
so yeah we had a uh dramatic saved by
the dragon moment uh Daemon was saved by
none other than lane or valerion on the
dragon sea smoke so you may not recall
who Lane over larion is
um so here's the family tree
so call us for larion's family Lord call
us uh he has his wife rhaenis and he has
his two children Lena and Lenor we did
see Lenor in previous episodes
as a younger child this is Young Lenor
I'm so sorry that this is the only
picture we have of Leno but this is the
official picture that HBO is using I'm
so sorry to that actor because he has
such a goofy face in this photo but
that's young lanor and we saw him at the
tournament with his sister Elena
and this episode is uh this new episode
is a few years later so this is Lenor
grown up the son of the sea snake
um
it looks like he's grown an awful lot
because it's only been about three or
four years since the previous episode
um Allison has given birth to a son uh
the son of Prince uh the son of King
viserys and Alison Hightower is this
little baby aegon
um which creates a rivalry with
viserys's daughter Rainier but yeah
we're a few years later and Lenor is a
dragon rider because he is the son of
rhaenys Targaryen and to answer your
question Kate yeah like these Valerian
children of rhino Targaryen uh Lenor at
least can ride dragons because he's got
that Targaryen blood so it's not just
the name Targaryen that gives you the
ability to ride dragons it's having that
blood of the Dragon it seems some sort
of genetic like a magical property of
the Targaryen bloodline and that's part
of why the targaryens mostly marry their
own sisters a egg on the Conqueror
married his sisters Balon married his
sister King joharis married his sister
because they want that dragon writing
genetics to stay in the family
in the Royal bloodline and if it was
that rhaenys became Queen uh and then
you know Lena or lane or inherited the
throne after rhaenys then the Dragon
Riders still would be the Royal line but
Lenor is a dragon rider who is not a
king because because viserys became King
instead so it is it is a weird situation
where there are Dragon Riders who are
not targaryens and are not in line for
the throne
um dragons are certainly like a symbol
of royalty but yeah Elena was a dragon
rider his dragon is called sea smoke and
he saved Daemon from the triaki thanks
to the Super Chat from Zoe who says if
Rainier and Cole are the only ones to
see the white heart will anyone else
recognize it as an omen yeah so we had
King viserys uh going on a hunt a big
fun Festival where everyone got together
and went hunting with the king in
celebration of his son the little baby
king aegon uh his second name day I
think it was so we see that Allison and
viserys have had a baby
um and there's this big festival and I
love how viserys is saying you know I
came here to hunt I'm here to just have
fun but while he's like scooping onions
onto his plate everyone's saying oh
we've got to deal with this war we've
got to deal with the succession but like
viserys is like I just want to eat my
onions I really liked viserys's stress
um and frustration with the politics and
with his family but yeah like they were
going out to hunt a white heart and a
white heart is a white deer
um and it is historically a symbol of
royalty as Ryan Condell explained in the
inside the episode
um It's associated with kingship and I
get the sense that it's like you know if
you see or if you capture the white
heart it's like a symbol that you are
legitimate you are like chosen by God to
be the king because in Real History the
white heart was a symbol of royalty and
so it's really interesting that you know
King viserys and everybody went out on
this hunt to to kill the white heart
um as a sort of a good omen which would
be associated with aegon his son his
baby son aegon Targaryen
um but in the end viserys only found a
normal stag a normal Brown Deer it was
Rainier who finds the white heart and
the way the white heart appears to
Rainier you know it's so Majestic and
it's peaceful and you know she doesn't
try to kill it she respects it and that
sort of fits with something that is said
in the books about a white heart so in
the first Game of Thrones book a similar
thing happens where a white heart is
cited in the Kingswood we are told
and then Sansa says that she has like a
special dream about the white heart this
is in the first Game of Thrones book
Sansa says I had a dream that Joffrey
would be the one to take the white heart
it had been more of a wish actually but
it sounded better to call it a dream
everyone knew that dreams were prophetic
white Hearts were supposed to be very
rare and magical and in her heart she
knew her Gallant Prince was worthier
than his drunken Father Robert
but when they do find the white heart in
the Game of Thrones book The White heart
has already been killed by wolves so
that itself is sort of a bad Omen about
Joffrey and about Robert at the time
um so you know so my point is that the
fact that rhaenyra sees the white heart
you could see that as a sign that
rhaenyra is the true legitimate Heir
chosen by God or whatever
so this might Inspire rhaenyra to think
yeah I am the true Heir not aegon the
baby aegon who was only represented by
this normal deer
and I loved the scene where viserys
killed the deer because it's so dark and
ominous and horrible like we just feel
awful for this deer and everybody
applauds after viserys kills it but it
just feels so like false and bad and
ominous which is a bad Omen for you know
aegon the baby
um yeah really dark thanks for the Super
Chat from shwami who says uh no uh no
spoilers here thanks for the Super Chat
from Sean who says George Martin finally
got his realistic Royal boar hunt party
must be HBO's way of apologizing for his
least favorite god scene yeah so in Game
of Thrones season one um the original TV
show we did have a quote-unquote hunting
scene where Robert went out on a hunt
but um that scene was considerably less
uh fancy than this big hunt we had like
the original Game of Thrones show did
not have the budget for the kind of like
you know giant Festival that we saw in
House of the Dragon so in Game of
Thrones season one it was literally just
Robert Baratheon his brother Renly
embarrassed and sell me and um Lancel
Lannister just walking in single file
through the forest with a spear no dogs
no horses no nothing and that was the
entirety of the hunting thing which you
know they didn't have a budget in Game
of Thrones season one so yeah it is
funny to see uh a proper big Royal hunt
in House of the Dragon which is what it
should have been what it should have
been all along
um and we did actually get to see a boar
um in this episode when a wild boar
attacked rhaenyra and Kristen Cole while
they were out uh having a cute camping
trip and rhaenyra
um finished off the boar after Kristen
wounded it
um I thought I thought it was slightly
silly the way that the boar the boar
like sort of knocked over rhaenyra and
and stood over rhaenyra and the ball
sort of like shook its head at rhaenyra
for a few seconds and I was like how is
Rainier not dead you know why is this
ball not I I don't know but um you know
as an emotional expression Rainier
stabbed stabbed the [ __ ] out of this paw
which shows her pent-up frustration and
anger over her situation because she
hates that you know she doesn't feel
like she has a place in the world now
because all the attention is on the new
baby son aegon and her new stepmother
Alison and we see how awkward Rainier's
relationship is with Allison now
um and so she feels really frustrated
and displaced and and replaced and so
she lets it out on the ball thanks for
the Super Chat from Jordan Krabs in the
chat links to the Super Chat from
Marcella deliveria who says is the
concept of my friend Rowan himself a
horse
yes everyone is a horse uh everyone who
was on a horse is a horse Lucy says no
crab fight super disappointing I can
understand if people find it
underwhelming like the death of the crab
feeder because he did seem like such a
massive villain but we didn't even see
him like say anything in this entire
show did we he got no dialogue I did
find it kind of funny
um in the opening scenes when we had we
had this valerion Knight who was like
being nailed to the beach by the crab
feeder and I feel like the Valerian
night uh he he it was it was nice of him
to drop so much Exposition while he was
being like crucified you know he said oh
house valerion is coming for you the sea
snake Corliss and Daemon [ __ ] you Prince
like he uses the title Prince Dreher
while he's being nailed it was very
helpful of this guys who uh you know
name all of the important characters to
remind us of the players in this story
thanks to the Super Chat from Johnny
Wolf uh thanks for the super jet from
soda water who brings up viserys who was
yeah not having a good time and and I
think that the reason why viserys is not
having a good time
in this episode is because he genuinely
cares I feel like that's that's
viserys's problem like if viserys just
said nope I'm gonna marry Rainier off
and I'm choosing my heir to be Rainier
or whatever and you know I mean my point
is like he needs to make a decision and
stick to it but viserys is doubting
himself constantly because he has so
much sympathy and care for Rainier and
for Alison like viserys wants everyone
to be happy like he says this episode
that you know no matter what I do I'm
pissing someone off if if viserys didn't
care so much about everybody's feelings
all the time I think he would have an
easier time of sticking to his decisions
but viserys doesn't just want his house
to be strong he wants his house to be
strong and he wants his daughter Rainier
to be happy and he wants to eatmon to be
happy anyone's callers to be happy and
he wants Otto to be happy and you can't
please everyone at once and I think that
is
um viserys's problem and you know we see
viserys drinking a lot the this episode
which is not a great coping mechanism
and it is reminiscent again of Robert
Baratheon Robert baratheon's drinking
while he was on a royal Hunt is what got
him killed in Game of Thrones season one
Robert was killed by a boar
um so you know it does feel kind of
ominous to see viserys echoing
um Robert in this way
um I liked how in Game of Thrones season
six we did get a little scene of um we
got to see this play where Robert was on
his hunt and then the boar killed Robert
in season six episode five
so we've seen many iterations of Royal
hunts and boars and things uh thanks for
Super Chat from night King who says why
was Daemon touching crab feeder he's
gonna get grayscale yes
yeah I thought uh like like the last
shot of the episode Daemon was covered
in the crab feeder's blood which seems
like a terrible idea given that the crab
feeder has grayscale which is like a
highly communicable disease
um the the grayscale thing is not in the
books
um the books don't mention crab feeder
having grayscale I think they just added
that to the show to you know give the
crab feeder something interesting
visually and and I do like the idea we
talked in our video last week that
um
the idea that grayscale might make a
person more dangerous and more crazy
because they've got nothing to lose and
the grayscale disease can affect
people's brain but the thing about
grayscale is that um it comes in several
different forms so there is the
grayscale version that will you know
turn you into a zombie man and make you
a monster
um but there's also the form of
grayscale that doesn't kill you it just
disfigures you and then stops
um and so an example of that is Shireen
Baratheon so Shireen Baratheon in Game
of Thrones had a case of grayscale when
she was very young but the form of
grayscale that she had was one which
eventually goes dormant and it stops uh
killing you at a certain point so
Shireen is no longer contagious at this
point so I guess you could speculate
that maybe the crab feeder also has that
form of grayscale which is no longer
contagious but the interesting thing
about Shireen in the books
is that like you know everyone like no
one's worried about a grayscale anymore
except for the character Val and and Val
is a um is a book only character uh
where is she here's
here's some artwork of Val by drizenka
Kimball Val is a wildling princess is
what she's called
um she is the sister of dala who is the
wife of Mance Raider who's the wildling
king and Val is this sort of badass
wildling chick who has a potential
romance with Jon Snow going on in the
books
um maybe she'll appear in the Jon Snow
sequel show if that happens but Val says
about Shireen she says Shireen is not
clean the girl has death inside her the
the gray plague sleeps only to awake
again so Val says that grayscale even if
you think that the grayscale is no
longer no longer contagious it actually
can still like come back and kill you or
something is what she seems to be saying
um this is sort of a tangent but um you
know uh my point is that if I was Daemon
I would not be bathing in the blood of
the diseased uh crab Vader thanks for
the Super Chat from neon taster who says
viserys wasn't missing one finger he was
missing two yeah so I'm not sure like
which shot maybe um yeah maybe here I
think that viserys was missing some
fingers so it looks as though viserys's
um
situation with his finger where he got a
cut uh has gone worse and worse and
worse and you really get the sense that
viserys is like falling apart you know
like his body is infected and rotting
um and also just like psychologically
like we see him drinking a whole lot
he's in a real sorry state in this scene
at the bonfire with Allison he's just
doubting himself
um he's really suffering under the
weight of his responsibilities and of
course yeah it's a very bad Omen that he
his fingers are falling off because of
the cut from The Throne uh thanks for
the donation from renak who says Daemon
definitely should have gotten grayscale
look I mean maybe it was the dormant
form maybe it's fine thanks for the
Super Chat from Amir and beef swelling
who says beef swelling says I do not
understand how viserys ever rode
balerion he seems pretty Meek and laid
back to have ridden the biggest dragon
ever yeah so it is really really
interesting
um here's some some artwork by Jordi
Gonzalez
escamilla of balerion the black dread so
balerion was the biggest baddest
toughest dragon in the world
um and valerion was the dragon of aegon
the Conqueror who was the the guy who
created the Iron Throne all those years
ago balerion was so large that when
valerion flew over a town
um it would overshadow the entire town
it would cast the whole place into
Shadow and valerion was so fearsome and
dangerous
um and you know vicenya's dragon vagon
is still around but Valerian was the
biggest and baddest and viserys rode
balerion
um
the biggest weapon of war the world has
ever seen But then balerion died of old
age like shortly after viserys rode
balerion and viserys never rode another
Dragon because it seems as though once
you ride one Dragon you can never ride
another Dragon you bond with that Dragon
for Life whereas a dragon because
dragons live much longer than humans
dragons can bond with multiple Riders
um like karaxi's daemon's Dragon was
originally ridden by daemon's Uncle
aemon
so it is really interesting that viserys
rode this badass dragon but then he said
oh you shouldn't have a ride dragons
they're too dangerous we can't control
them and maybe that makes me think that
maybe when viserys was younger he was
more gung-ho he was more aggressive he
was more risk-taking but maybe he had an
experience with valerion that changed
his mind that scared him maybe you know
like maybe maybe viserys struggled to
control valerion maybe balerion did
something scary and dangerous and
violent and viserys was horrified by
that maybe we'll get some sort of reveal
like that in the show I think that'll be
really cool
um
because yeah it's a really interesting
contradiction in viserys's character
um and we see how you know sometimes
targaryens are scared by their dragons
sometimes the targaryens fail to control
their dragons like Daenerys sometimes
fails to control drogon and Daenerys is
horrified when drogon eats children
um and so she locks up her dragons in
book five and season five
um because she's afraid of what her
dragons can do so yeah this is not
without precedent uh thanks for the
Super Chat from smellsish who says three
episodes in and we zoom in through time
already five years from the start of the
first episode I think it was like six
months between one and two and it's like
three years between two and three so
it's been a few years yeah and I and I
do feel like the appearance of the
characters does not necessarily make
sense like Lenor went from a little baby
to a grown ass man in those four years
whereas rangiora and Ellison haven't
changed at all but you know that's just
the realities of casting I guess uh
thanks for the donation from zephilis
who said loved the symbolism of viserys
missing fingers to show how the rot has
progressed yeah and the rot has
progressed due to his refusal to remove
the fingers I think that's a really good
point zephilios
um like if viserys was more decisive and
if visceros just like did the decisive
conclusive thing and cut off the rotten
fingers then maybe the rot would stop
but because viserys refuses to make a
clear decision
um the rot continues and I think that's
like an analogy for viserys's decisions
with his succession like viserys thinks
of rhaenyra as his Heir still but as we
saw like you know Thailand Lannister and
a lot of people or Jason Lannister
with bloody twins can't tell them apart
um a lot of people think of the new baby
aegon as the out of the throne despite
viserys's wishes and since he you know
he doesn't Force rhaenyra to marry off
he doesn't like he doesn't like say hey
everyone aegon is not the air you know
like he sort of vacillates he tries to
have it both ways but if he did
something more decisive cut off the
finger maybe the rod would stop
um zephilius also says that Lenor looked
as though he was going to say something
about pod racing after the cheer on
Dragon back I literally thought the same
thing when Lanos swooped in on his
dragon and he said like woo or something
while he was flying the dragon uh yeah I
absolutely got some pod racing Vibes but
I'm glad that we got to see Leno on on
seismic because Lena and sea smoke is
not mentioned taking apart in this war
in the books but it totally makes sense
that he would be here
um since the valerions are taking part
since Corliss is taking part of course
Leno's son on Dragon back would would be
involved
um in the books I talk about how that
like the soldiers that they mentioned
they mostly talk about how Daemon
gathered a bunch of like adventurers and
mercenaries and second sons and it it's
it sounds as though it's mostly demons
people who form the Army in the books
um but I like how here you know this is
a valerion military operation that
Daemon is taking part in mostly because
of
um mostly because he's got a bloody
dragon and the dragons are so important
militarily thanks for the Super Chat
from Jacob who says kragus got War
crimed yeah it is so wrong that Daemon
used a peace Banner only to betray them
uh Lord strong is a beast caraxi stays
winning is viserys alcoholic maxing yeah
you just like see the look on viserys's
face when he gets more and more stressed
and he just drinks more and more and it
is not great
um and yeah we did see Lionel strong
Lord of Haron Hall pushing uh the
valerion the valerians as potential
um spouses for the targaryens uh Lionel
strong was saying that Rainier should
marry Lenor valerion
uh which is probably a smart idea right
because the valerians are really angry
that
um viserys didn't marry a valerion and
rhaenys was kept off the Throne of the
Harren Hall Council rhaenyra marrying
Plano you'd think could solve a lot of
problems and you know it would bring the
valerion dragon right Elena back into
the Targaryen fold you know because it
does seem very dangerous to have another
family having Dragon Riders and having
the the blood of the Dragon uh thanks
for the Super Chat from dwan who says I
love the idea that Otto needed a bit of
a push from his brother to push the
issue of succession I think he genuinely
cares for the realm yeah it was
interesting to have this conversation
between
Otto Hightower the hand of the king and
Hobart Hightower the Lord of Old Town
and we saw hobo Hobart sort of ordering
Otto around and saying hey you need to
get your grandson baby aegon to be the
heir to the throne
um and you know it he he seems like a
sort of an arrogant guy he was sort of
pushing Otto around which is really
interesting because like also
Otto has always sort of seemed like the
one in charge when we've seen it when
we've seen him but now we see that Otto
seems to be operating on hobart's wishes
a bit
um we saw
Otto writing a letter to Old Town in
season one episode one
so maybe he was writing to Otto to tell
him hey by the way I've sent my daughter
to go and have sex with the King but one
of the things that we didn't talk about
was the idea that
um in the previous episode you know we
saw Otto tell Alison hey you should you
should go and visit the king tonight and
some people I've seen people online say
that hey look Alison uh was wearing the
same dress
um
the following morning like she went and
visited
um King viserys
and then the next morning yeah here we
are so at the end of the previous
episode Alison was wearing this blue
dress which is the same dress that
Alison was wearing when Otto told her at
night time you should go and visit the
king and some people have seen this as
evidence that Alison slept with viserys
and had sex
um wearing the same clothes the next
morning Walk of Shame Shame
um and therefore maybe part of the
reason why viserys said he would marry
Alison was because he was worried that
you know since he took Allison's
virginity and potentially even got her
pregnant it would be a huge dishonor to
Alison
um unless he married her like if she was
deflowered and had a child out of
wedlock that would be a huge problem
politically
um so there's the idea that maybe
because they had sex that's why viserys
married her and we don't you know this
is just speculation we don't know if
they actually had sex but it is
um it is with precedent because like Rob
Stark in Game of Thrones drones and in
the books hooked up with this woman
Talisa
and in the books he hooked up with this
girl Jane westerling and part of the
reason why he married Jane westerling
was because he had sex with her in like
a fit of passion and teenage horniness
and in order to not dishonor her that's
why he married her to protect her honor
it was The Honorable thing to do so
maybe something similar happened with
viserys thanks for the Super Chat from
uh Milan who says real dragons have two
legs yet the sigil has four I've seen
many explanations for this but curious
on your thoughts yeah I yeah I don't
really have an answer here
um so you know the Targaryen sigil is
represented a lot of different ways
um in the TV show it's represented
me find a good
uh Targaryen in the TV show The
Targaryen sigil looks like this
um usually so it's a three-headed dragon
with two legs but in House of the Dragon
for some reason well that one's also got
two legs but some of the time it's got
four legs uh which is weird because none
of the actual dragons we've seen have
four legs but I think that uh Ryan
condle the show runner was pointing out
that in season six episode 10 and in
some other spots Daenerys used a
four-legged dragon and so he's trying to
like connect that symbolism to make it
seem connected I don't know if it's
actually important either way maybe it
was a production [ __ ] up that they're
just trying to paper over I don't know
we'll see what happens but I don't know
if the sigil is super important thanks
for the Super Chat from first name who
says why do they keep lying to us by
saying that no woman has sat the throne
when both vicenia and rhaenys sat the
throne and competently held Court
whenever aegon was away that would be a
useful precedent for rhaenyra yeah
that's a good point yeah I mean the
people keep saying oh there's never been
a woman on the throne there's never been
a queen
um but yeah aegon and vicenia
sorry rhaenys and visenya the wives of
aegon the Conqueror
um they had a big influence politically
and they did hold Court while aegon was
away sometimes
um here's the artwork by amok
um
and so they certainly are a precedent of
women holding power and also like
joharis's wife alisane was really
influential politically I think like
even more than them there's um Alyssa
valerion this artworks by Chile Raven
art so in the books
um Alyssa valerion was the wife of Anis
and the mother of King jahiris and while
jaharis was young Alyssa was the Regent
of the realm like she was in charge
um similar to how like Cersei is the
Regent for tommen in Game of Thrones so
like Alyssa valerion and her husband
Roger Baratheon were running the show
while jahiris and alisane were young
um
so yeah I mean there absolutely are
examples of women
um setting the throne literally and
having political power and yeah you
would think that rhaenyra should bring
this up but I mean rhaenyra shouldn't
need to bring it up because you know her
father named her the air and all these
Lords dozens of Lords bent the knee and
swore loyalty to her so so none of this
should even be relevant you know they
said that she's there and you know and
they talk about oh you know the the
precedent there's never been a a queen
and whatever
um but yeah and you know the maesters
say that oh you know the harrenhall
council that means that no no woman will
ever sit the throne but that's just one
interpretation of the Heron Hall Council
I mean you could you could argue that
the harrenhall council all the Harren
Hall Council really meant was that
viserys was a preferable King to um
to rhaenys or lanor
um
you know because he's a an adult male
with a you know
I don't know there's different opinions
on the Precedence thanks for the Super
Chat from Johnny who says how big is
karaxi's supposed to be is he bigger or
stronger than uh dragon
um that I mean I've seen you know stuff
online you know size comparisons of all
the dragons that you know this is how
much dragons weigh George Martin does
not tell us the the you know cubic
weight and height and width of all these
dragons he doesn't describe that in a
lot of detail he just says what color
they are and he says that you know Vega
vegar is the biggest alive
um you know I mean Cyrax Rainier is
dragon is younger and smaller caraxy's
becomes pretty big I mean it's mostly
about age is the size thing and karaxi's
has been around longer than
um Cyrax and and sea smoke and stuff so
yeah caraxis is one of the larger
dragons but it's not as big as Vega but
it is larger than Cyrax it's sort of in
between
um I enjoyed seeing Daemon just burning
people
um I really enjoyed when Daemon got hit
by an arrow while he was on caraxi's and
caraxi's sort of squawked and cried out
as though in pain
um so it seems as though when Daemon
feels pain his Dragon also feels pain
because of that bond that they have
there's a lot of speculation that the
connection between a Targaryen and their
dragon is similar to the connection
between a stark and their direwolf like
you know how a lot of the Starks are
wargs who can connect with their animals
through some psychic power and some of
the wildlings are too they can feel what
their wolf feels
um I think that it may be similar with
the targaryens they have like a psychic
bond with their dragons I also liked
seeing how Daemon used his dragon's Wing
as like a shield against arrows
um it's just cool to see details like
that about like how Dragon combat and
dragon flying works because we haven't
got a lot of those details in the books
but I think it all makes sense thanks
for the Super Chat from person who says
do you think we are ever gonna get
mushroom I don't want him to have a
speaking role just to be there because
he's allowed yeah so in the book Fire
and Blood there is a character called
mushroom this Art Is by Rossi does
drawings and mushroom is a dwarf with a
gigantic head and a gigantic penis at
least he claims to have a gigantic penis
and mushroom is one of the historical
sources that the book is based on and
while Eustis and Monken are very serious
and proper about what supposedly
happened uh mushroom is constantly
saying those people boned and those
people boned and they boned at the same
time yeah they yeah so he's he has all
these salacious rumors all the time um
so he's just he's just like a fun funny
character and he should be in the story
because he was the jester for
um King viserys and for several other
characters so
um you'd hope that he would appear and
in an interview of Ryan gondle by uh by
westeros.org there's a video on YouTube
they asked uh Ryan Condell about
mushroom and Ryan Condell said yes
saying that mushroom would appear at
some point so yeah apparently we will
see Mushroom in the show which would be
fun and I agree I don't want mushroom to
have a speaking role necessarily just as
like a cameo for the book Raiders I
think would be cool thanks for the Super
Chat from Camille who says I have the
feeling that Alison will become very
soon a big politics player I saw the
next episode I feel she will play a big
part yes I agree so we had a
conversation between
Otto and Alison where
um
it seems as though Alison is really
starting to uh internalize Otto's
lessons
um because Allison says something here
about how
um you know you've got to make a call is
basically what Allison was saying
um Allison to sort of urging viserys to
be more pragmatic and we've got to
wonder if Alison might start pushing for
the rights of her son baby aegon like
Alison in the previous episodes has been
very sort of uncomfortable and not sure
of herself and she just sort of goes
along with what's happening whereas I
think now we're starting to see her
become more assertive because Allison
has skin in the game Alison has her baby
um and you know the life of her baby the
the place of her baby depends on uh its
political place and so you know if
Allison can push for her baby to become
king of Westeros that would
um that would benefit her that would
benefit her family and the other thing
is that you know it's about safety as
well because
you know even if Allison just says you
know okay rhaenyra is Heir my baby is
not the heir that's all fine we accept
that rhaenyra is Queen whatever even if
she does that her baby's life is still
potentially in danger because there's a
long history of
potential claimants potential rival
claimants being roped into plots like
even like it's just a little kid right
what if you know
or someone just said you know I want
aegon to be the king and I'm going to
start a war for aegon to be the king I'm
gonna marry or betroth aegon to my
daughter and we're going to start a war
to put them on the throne so even if
aegon and Allison don't want aegon on
the throne aegon could be used in a plot
or rhaenyra might see baby aegon as a
threat and you know when viserys dies
and if rhaenyra becomes Queen what if
rhaenyra says well we've got to kill
little baby aegon we've got to throw him
down a well because he might be a threat
to my legitimacy you know as long as
aegon is alive some Lords are gonna go
oh I would prefer aegon to be on the
throne instead of rhaenyra so like just
the existence of aegon and the existence
of rhaenyra makes them a threat to each
other
and that's why it is smart and it is a
good idea
um someone suggests to uh yeah I think
Otto suggests here
um to viserys maybe Rainier should marry
baby aegon
um because that would settle the issue
like rhaenyra and aegon will no longer
be rival claimants if they marry unite
the claims end the conflict that would
piss off the valerians probably uh
because that would mean the valerians
once again like miss out on an
opportunity to join the royal family
um so you don't want to piss off the
valerians again but you know rhaenyra
marrying out aegon could solve a lot of
problems and it's so funny that
viserys's reaction when Otto says hey
you should marry Rainier to baby aegon
viserys is like ew like that's so gross
to to marry rhaenyra like they have such
a large age Gap that's so gross which is
[ __ ] hilarious given that
um viserys just went on a date with you
know bloody lainer valerion the little
kid
um and then he decided to marry Allison
who is I think Allison was meant to be
14 years old at the time
um and viserys is what he's in his 40s
I guess
um in the books viserys is only like uh
28 or something or 38.
uh I don't remember right now but um
there's a very large age gap between
Alison and and viserys so it's funny
that viserys is grossed out by the age
gap between baby aegon and rhaenyra and
and obviously if they did marry rhaegon
and uh rhaenyra and aegon
um it would probably just be a betrothal
until the boy is old enough and I guess
that would be a complication because you
know you would have to wait like uh 14
years before you can
seal the deal and consummate the
marriage because part of the idea with
marriages is that until the newlyweds
have sex
the marriage is not a done deal because
before they have sex you can undo a
marriage you can annul a marriage until
they've had sex then you can't annul it
so you'd have to wait a while before
aegon and Rainier could consummate and
cement the marriage thanks for the Super
Chat from dwan who says who's better at
self-sabotage Rainier or Cersei is
rhaenyra self-sabotaging herself I mean
like if ifrinero wants the throne she
should marry someone
um I mean if rhaenyra wants a thorn she
should marry lanor because Lenor has a
dragon which is like such a symbol of
legitimacy and the valerians have such
close ties to the throne and like you
know rhaenys and corley's would be huge
allies to like support rhaenyra's claim
um if rhaenyra wants the throne she
should be seeking allies she shouldn't
just be complaining but that's a thing
like rhaenyra is not acting like a
politician rhaenyra is acting like a
teenager because rhaenyra is a teenager
um
I really enjoyed the scene where
rhaenyra was sitting on the Heart Tree
in the godswood uh and she was telling
this Minstrel whose name was Samwell
Play the song again about nymeria I
think it was a song about princess
nymeria and her 10 000 ships uh and you
know she was basically treating this
[ __ ] like an iPod Shuffle like
she was just saying play the same song
but play despacito on repeat while I
read my book
um which I thought was just very funny
it's just teenage Behavior like she is
quite mean to people she is quite mean
to Samwell the minstrel Samwell the the
the human uh Zune the the human iPod
Nano
um right here is kind of mean to people
but you know it's because she's a
teenager like Rainier is meant to be I
think about 17 years old was it 17 or
18.
um and you know she's just grumpy and
she's you know hormonal as any teenager
is and um she's sort of letting out her
frustrations on the world
um so you know like like being a
teenager is hard enough without having
to be the heir to the throne and deal
with all this politics at the same time
so you know I I think that Rainier
Rainier is not acting in like a
politically Smart Way
um and she's also not making it easy for
her father but you know I think that's
realistic I think that's how teenagers
are sometimes I mean there is that idea
of like you know do medieval people get
to be teenagers because you know in this
world when you turn 16 you're considered
an adult so you're not really allowed to
have this idea of having a sort of
rebellious teenage transition between
childhood and adulthood uh you meant to
just turn 16 and start popping out
sprogs and cutting off heads because uh
welcome to Westeros
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
sporian who says someone get that pug
some more cake yes there was a pug uh
which I enjoyed so much uh where was the
Pug the Pug was in the scene where uh oh
we got to see Lara strong actually we
got to talk about Lara strong
um
where was Bloody Lara strong so yeah all
right so we had this you know Royal tent
where everyone was hanging out before
the hunt and by the way what it what a
tent could you imagine being the guy who
has to carry all of the decorative jugs
and vases to decorate the tent what a
what a ridiculous uh luxury but we had
all of the women folk who had come along
for the hunt and of course the men go
riding and the women stay and they
gossip
um and some of the gossip was quite
interesting actually so one of the uh
one of the women says one of Lord's
Swan's ships sailed through the
stepstones and Lord Swan's uh daughter
Johanna Swann was abducted by the tryaki
and that's a detail that's taken
straight out of the books so the
stepstones the this whole War that's
going on
um it's happening because these
[ __ ] called the triarchy have taken
over the stepstones islands and they're
in an important shipping route
um and so callus wants to remove them
um and in the books it talks about how
when the triarchy took over the
stepstones
um Westeros didn't mind at first and you
know viserys says so in episode one of
this show he says oh the triaki has
killed the Pirates on the stepstones
great less Pirates that's a good thing
that's good news and and that is that
that is from the book like the Westeros
was like cool great I I I'm glad the
triarchy of replaced the Pirates but
then the triaki became worse than the
Pirates the chaiyaki started taxing
everyone who came through the stepstones
um and it these taxes were so heavy that
they were worse than the bloody Pirates
ever worse ever were
um and not only were were the triarchy
taxing people they started kidnapping
and enslaving people who came through
the stepstones
um specifically they took girls and boys
to be taken as sex slaves in the
pleasure houses of lease
um so they were straight up selling
people into sexual slavery which was you
know what started to make Westeros uh
Angry and started seeing the trayaki and
the crab feeder as enemies
um and Johanna Swann is one of the
people who got taken by the triaki and
sold into sexual slavery and the books
mentioned that oh and by the way you
know Johanna Johanna Swann actually uh
did pretty well in the pleasure houses
and became like the ruler of the brothel
and she was known as the Black Swan and
she was wait was it the Black Swan
that's like that Aronofsky movie isn't
it uh basically George Martin just
started having a Black Swan uh fantasy
about a um girl taking over a brothel
there's a lot of sort of um young people
getting involved in salacious sexual
activities in the book which it's a bit
much it's a bit much I think uh there's
a lot of it
um and I think that hot D has mostly
sidestepped it but uh yeah it's straight
from the books and it is really nice to
see how closely the show is sticking to
the books like so many of these little
details are from the books thanks for
the Super Chat from oh yeah and the Pug
did we see the pug I did love that
someone was like feeding their pug
um cake from the plate and it is
hilarious like it's like in uh June in
the David Lynch June movie uh the
Atreides just had a pug and Patrick
Stewart uh rode into battle carrying a
pug in the June movie it's just bizarre
I I almost feel it's a similar it's a
similar Vibe with this pug I like it
very much
but we also met Laris strong
um so Lara strong is this fellow here
and he is the younger son of Lionel
strong uh and he is the younger brother
of harwinstrong who we haven't properly
met yet uh and while ho and strong is
like a badass Knight who's like the
strongest warrior in the realm
supposedly Laris strong has a club foot
he has like a oddly shaped foot which
means that he can't walk comfortably he
has this cane and he can't fight and so
Lara strong has other ways that he
um operates in the world it's a little
bit like Tyrion Lannister is a dwarf so
you know he can't be a warrior so he
finds he uses his mind and he uses his
wits and he finds other ways of having a
place in the world and you know I
thought it was really interesting how
larus came in and he said like you know
the gods have not shaped me for uh the
hunt so can I sit with the women and so
it really frames it as like a gendered
thing you know Laris can't fit into the
male gender role so therefore he takes
on the uh the more feminine role of you
know sitting and eating cookies and I
love his like side eye like Rainier
insults one of these ladies by saying
that she eats cake
um
and like and Laris strong Lara strong is
just sitting here taking in the gossip
so you know I I won't spoil his role in
the future but it's interesting to see
larys just observing just watching just
listening and um we'll see where that
leads keep your eyes on Lara strong uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Sebastian
uh yeah we talked about the grayscale I
I think um it's possible that
um The Crab feeders form of grayscale
was a non-contagious form like Shireen
and so I think that's why Daemon uh may
not get grayscale from the crab feeder
thanks for the Super Chat from jinxes
who says lots of death and symbolism
this episode thoughts on viserys killing
the Stag and Daemon killing the valerion
Knight by landing on him yeah that was
that was kind of a ridiculous moment
where um this Valerian Knight was like
you know begging for mercy from the
skies and he's saying yeah Daemon has
come to save the day and then daemon's
Dragon karaxi's instantly just steps on
this guy and squashes him which I think
comes across as almost a comedic moment
um but yeah it's I mean when you really
think about it it's it's bloody awful
that this Knight knew that he was going
to be eaten alive by crabs and he was I
think he was begging for Daemon to burn
him with fire so he didn't have to get
eaten alive by crabs it's really very
dark but the fact that you know Daemon
and karaxi's just stomped on him it does
sort of suggest that Daemon doesn't give
a [ __ ] about people very much I mean you
gotta remember that this whole War like
the whole reason Daemon is here and like
burning hundreds of men alive is because
he wants glory he wants attention he
wants validation he wants to prove how
big his dick is by burning a bunch of
people alive
um and you know the the fact that Daemon
didn't want viserys's help the fact that
he was angry about viserys sending him
reinforcements shows that it's not about
winning the war he's not just being
pragmatic he wants to personally win he
wants to do it himself to prove how
tough he is
um
so yeah look he's a bit of a [ __ ] is
is all I'm trying to say a lot of people
you know in the fandom are saying oh you
know daemon's a cool guy he's not really
that bad I mean the showrunner Ryan
Condell said that oh daemon's not a
monster he loves his family at heart but
can we remember that in episode 1 like
Daemon was killing these like civilians
who were supposedly
um supposedly they were criminals and
murderers like we saw Daemon with his
gold cloaks killing all these people
um and we saw Daemon like taking great
pleasure in like killing a guy
personally
um cutting off all these hands in the
books it says that you know Daemon took
Delight in mutilating people which seems
like the textbook definition of evil to
me like if you have to kill somebody
that's one thing but if you are enjoying
mutilating people who you know may or
may not really be guilty of anything
seems to me that Daemon is pretty evil
but you know that that's up to
interpretation
thanks for Super Chat from Philippe who
enjoyed viserys's binge drinking thanks
for the Super Chat from Nono who says
the first sigil in the intro is the doom
and the Three Dragons fleeing in the top
right corner barely visible a hint of
them causing it oh that's an interesting
point no no so uh so yes the first image
in the intro sequence is of the Doom of
valyria which is when the old Empire of
the dragonlords was destroyed in a
mysterious catastrophe volcanoes erupted
sulfur fell from the skies it might have
been related to magic it might have been
related to The Faceless Men but one of
the theories about the Doom is that it
may have been caused by
um the targaryens because you know it's
very interesting that the targaryens
found out it was going to happen before
it happened and that's how they escaped
it and the targaryens say that ah you
know my daughter danis the dreamer she
had a dream about the doom and that's
why we left but some people say that's a
bit of a convenient excuse what if the
targaryens deliberately caused the Doom
of valyria by say hiring Faceless Men to
assassinate the sorcerers who kept the
14 Flames from erupting maybe the
targaryens caused the Doom to make
themselves the only dragon riders in the
world
because the books mention how the
targaryens the targaryens were not one
of the most powerful families in valyria
um they were one of the Lesser houses
like it sounds like there were sort of
dozens of powerful families and houses
the targaryens were one of the less
powerful houses in valyria so by the
destruction of valyria the targaryens
went from one of the less powerful
Dragon riding families to the only
dragon riding family
um so maybe the targaryens did the doom
and Nono points out that it looks as
though you can slightly see some dragons
like flying away from valyria in the
background here maybe that represents
the targaryens leaving
um having caused the Doom maybe but
that's just a theory thanks for the
Super Chat from Davey who says do the
Boars in A Song of Ice and Fire like
attacking royalty can't blame bloodraven
for that one
yeah so you know there is a fun theory
that you know in uh Game of Thrones book
one season one when Robert Baratheon
gets killed by a boar some people
theorize that bloodraven may have sent
the boar so bloodraven is the tree dude
um he is he he's this guy who uh trains
bran in how to be a tree Wizard and in
the books this guy bloodraven has a very
long and complicated and cool history
which you can learn all about in the alt
shift x video about bloodraven
um and blood Raven one of his powers is
that you know as a green Seer with the
magic of the old gods bloodraven can
control animals just like bran can
um and so there's a lot of hints that
bloodraven has been using his powers to
influence events this guy Jill Mormont
um the Lord commander of the Night's
Watch who you know is John's Mentor Joe
Mormont in the books has a raven which
is sort of comic relief like it keeps
asking for corn all the time and stuff
um but the Raven occasionally does
things that seem suspiciously
intelligent and political like the Raven
helps Jon Snow become the new Lord
commander of the Night's Watch because
it says snow snow like the Raven talks
um and the Raven also like appears on
John's chest and like squawks at him
while Jon is having a dream about the
white walkers and the long night it
seems to be so it seems as though
bloodraven is controlling the Raven from
afar as a way of influencing events
possibly like he gave Jon that dream
um so since the Raven is manipulating
events
um maybe there are other animals that
bloodraven is using to influence events
maybe bloodraven sent the pig that
killed King Robert I don't think that's
likely to be true but it is a fun theory
that it's also suggested that maybe
bloodraven uh controlled the direwolves
uh that came to the Stark children at
the start of the book
um like maybe bloodraven is the reason
Bran Got The Wolf and became a org
because that led to bran being
bloodraven student but you know that's
not super relevant thanks for the Super
Chat from Alexander who says love the
symbolism three-way parallel between
viserys's purely ritual hunt whereas
Rainier are killing in a real fight for
her life versus demon hunting a human
yeah yeah I I like the sort of falseness
of you know viserys quote-unquote hunts
this uh deer but he you know he doesn't
personally chase down the deer they just
present the deer to him so that viserys
can kill him it's not a real hunt it's
not a real accomplishment by viserys and
it's just this sort of horrible
unnecessary killing
um it didn't mean anything whereas
rhaenyra killed this boar that was
attacking her it was a real like
hot-blooded violent situation
whereas yeah Daemon went and killed a
human for his own sort of reasons so
yeah it was sort of three different
kinds of violence for different reasons
that each say something about their
character like viserys didn't even seem
to want to kill the deer he just sort of
did it because he had to didn't really
mean anything but he just sort of felt
obliged whereas rhaenyra was like
letting out her feelings when she killed
the boar and there was sort of real
danger to it
um so it's sort of understandable you
know that she did that but also it was
very scary how she you know she just
stabbed the [ __ ] out of it and there was
blood all over her and you know it was a
bit scary how rhaenyra got so violent
for no good reason and Daemon was just
being a [ __ ] I mean I mean like you
know yes he was ending the war in the
stepstones but he did it in the way that
created the most possible personal glory
for him and he used a false peace Banner
which is a really like dick move that
undermines the conventions of War so
um yeah these three acts of violence
each say a very different thing about
each character
um I also really really enjoyed viserys
talking about his dreams so viserys
revealed something new here visera said
that
um he he had a dream about having a male
son and a male Heir and the reason why
he chose rhaenyra to be his Heir instead
was because he gave up believing in his
dream of having a son
um he sort of lost faith in his dream I
no longer believed he said
um he changed his mind but now that he
has aegon he's starting to have doubts
he's like oh no like my dream about
having a son did come true after all
um and so now he's like maybe I made a
mistake by naming rhaenyra is sort of
his thought and it's interesting that
you know since viserys did not find the
white heart he found a normal deer
instead that suggests that well okay
like
um the mystical sign of the air did not
appear for aegon the white heart is the
symbol of kingship and and we did not
find it on aegon's special hunt
um so maybe that confirms to viserys
that like yes okay well maybe aegon is
not the one who should be Heir it should
be Rainier and I think that another like
layer to the reason why viserys wants
Rainier instead of aegon is that viserys
told rhaenyra about the secret about
aegon's dream aegon's prophecy about the
white walkers
um that's part of why viserys wants
Rainier to inherit the throne because
she knows about that important dream
whereas aegon is a baby you know he he
can't very well say to baby aegon oh by
the way little goo goo gaga baby there's
gonna be white walkers and you're gonna
have to kill them
um viserys might be dead by the time
aegon is you know grown up enough to
understand the importance of that dream
and that prophecy so you know viserys
has entrusted Rainier with it because
she's old enough so you know
um I think that's part of viserys's
reasoning but like this whole idea like
we can see how tortured viserys is about
this dream that he had and doubting his
dreams and following his dreams but the
dream's not coming true and that's one
of the themes throughout the books and
the story is that dreams can [ __ ] you up
you know like wanting your dreams to
come true misinterpreting them doubting
yourself they can destroy you there's a
character in The Hedge Knight
in Duncan egg
um called dayron the drunken and he's a
Targaryen who is tortured by his dreams
um and he sort of misinterprets them and
wants them to come true but like he he
feels inadequate and he has all this
like Father issues because every bloody
character in the in the book says father
issues but he has these dream issues
um and that's ultimately what destroys
him his brother Amon maester aemon from
the main series
um says that you know dreams destroyed
my brothers everyone and I think we're
seeing the same thing happen to viserys
his dreams his Ambitions his hopes and
his conflicted feelings about them are
destroying him thanks for the Super Chat
from captrick who says rhaenyra and
Alison barely even seem like friends
anymore the Royal marriage really made
things worse for them yeah I mean I mean
that's part of the thing about you know
teenage friendships is that they can be
really intense but they can also be
brief because people are changing so
much when they're young and I think
Allison didn't an era have changed in
different ways they've sort of diverged
like you know Alison uses very formal
language with rhaenyra the king wishes
for you to join us like it's all very
formal and proper and that is of course
how the queen queen Alison should behave
because she is the wife of the king and
she needs to be formal and proper and
also she's focusing on her children I'm
sure she's spent a lot of time with her
children which means she's not spending
time with rhaenyra and so rhaenyra has
been left alone and feeling resentful
and feeling angry that her best friend
betrayed her by marrying her dad without
telling her it was happening and you
know is doing her own thing and also of
course as the political undercurrent of
will aegon be king or will Rainier have
the throne so
I think it's very understandable that
this friendship has gotten so tough and
you know it it's nice that they have
this conversation under the weirwood
tree in the red keep godswood because
that's where we saw them being such good
friends in episode one they were so
close and they were so intimate in this
exact place but a few years later in the
same place and it's um
it's and the Situation's changed and you
know Alison is wearing a red dress which
not only matches the weirwood leaves
very nicely but the red dress is the
Targaryen color which evokes her uh
Targaryen political Ambitions you know
putting aegon on the throne to replace
rhaenyra and you know Alison does not
seem like 100 on board the whole making
her baby the king thing that's more
Otto's thing that's more Otto's desire
but I think we can see Allison more and
more internalizing
Otto's desires and Otto's Ambitions she
is learning from other
um so we'll see how that develops thanks
for the Super Chat from Daniel who says
hope you're having a good day thank you
Daniel I hope you're having a good day
thanks for the Super Chat from Emma who
says any continuity with viserys losing
his finger to rot or any of his other
injuries continuity well yeah I mean
there is some similar stuff in the book
but you know we'll have to see how we'll
have to see what happens
um but yeah I really enjoyed someone in
no no in the Super Chat and pointed out
that you know maybe if viseris cut off
the finger in the first place this never
would have happened because in the
previous episode
um the maesters were telling viserys
like oh you know this is the best chance
of saving the digit like we won't have
to cut off your finger if we use the
maggots to you know heal your finger and
get rid of the rot but like we'll be
able to save the finger but clearly that
didn't work
um because it's just gotten worse and
worse so maybe the maces were wrong
maybe they should have cut off the
finger then he'd be fine and I think
that's a nice metaphor about viserys not
taking decisive action when he should
um Matt in the live chat says I saw a
Joffrey valerion yeah so I think that
was a mistake in the subtitles the
subtitles have not been great sometimes
uh in this season actually because yeah
um there is a character uh called
Joffrey but he's not Joffrey valerion he
is Joffrey lawnmuth
um and Joffrey lawnmuth is a friend of
Leno valerion uh and we may learn more
in future episodes uh but I think the
subtitles mistakenly uh called this
person Joffrey valerion when he's
actually Joffrey lawnmuth in the books
Joffrey elonmouth is called the Knight
of kisses because the lonmouth sigil has
red lips on it as well as skulls
um and lawnmuth there's a character
called Richard lonmouth who was The
Squire of rhaegar Targaryen in the time
of Robert's rebellion and um I think
there's a theory that radio Astros
Advanced that Richard longmeth is now
now Lim uh no not lamb Lam Lem yeah well
go check out radio Westeros they'll sort
you out about Richard lonmouth uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Liam who just
says do you think Daemon is going to get
grayscale and uh probably not
um but I think it's probably the dormant
form of grayscale that um
crab feeder had like Shireen thanks for
the Super Chat from Camillo who says did
you catch the guy with the blackfyre
logo hola Juan uh I did not catch a guy
with a Blackfire logo I mean I did say
that there was the master of Revels in
episode one who had a black dragon uh on
his belly
um so the so the black dragon sigil
um in the future in the blackfyre
rebellions era
um so years years after House of the
Dragon but years before Game of Thrones
there was this conflict called the
blackfyre rebellions and you can learn
all about the blackfyre rebellions in
the alt shift x video about the
blackfyre rebellions yeah this is the
blackfyre sigil
um
and
that has a great deal of significance in
the Blackfire period but you know in
this time the blackfyers don't exist yet
so I don't think the black dragon has
any special significance now I mean like
you know part of the tradition is that
when you have a
when you have a bastard
um sometimes the bastard has a reversed
heraldry like the colors are reversed
like how Stark is normally a uh gray
direwolf on white but Jon Snow uh in
theory would have a uh White direwolf on
on Gray like like a reversed colors is
what a bastard has sometimes and that's
why the target why the blackfyre dragon
is black because you reverse the colors
when you have a bastard
um and the blackfyers were a bastard
line of the targaryens um but yeah my
point is that I don't think the black
fire sigil is super significant right
now
uh no no says what was in it for crab
feeder a promised cure I mean yeah
that's a good question like like why was
the crab feeder doing all this like we
didn't get any dialogue from him at all
I don't think so you know we don't
really know what his motivations are I
mean we talked in the previous episode
um well viserys talked about how you
know crab feeder is funded by the
triarchy by the cities of lease and Mia
and Irish
um and so you know and Corliss I think
said that the triarchy is trying to
weaken Westeros so you know this is a
political power grab type thing I mean
also you know the crab feeder is making
money like at least in the books they're
taxing all of the trade that goes
through the narrow sea and they're
making a bunch of money which is
presumably going back to the triarchy so
you know partly this is about money
partly this is about political power and
I think for the crab feeder he clearly
enjoys feeding people to the crabs I
mean maybe he just loves crabs you know
he's he's a real environmentalist
um you know he has a a bond with the
crab people maybe he made a deal with
the Merlin King in in the books there is
stuff about the Deep ones which are like
these lovecraftian fish monsters that
may or may not be connected to the
religion of the drowned one the Drowned
God on the iron Islands uh maybe he made
a deal with Cthulhu crab thulu maybe
that's what's going on
thanks for the Super Chat from Tai who
says play this song when callus comes to
age Daemon uh watch it in your own time
sorry guys thanks for the Super Chat
from Kristen who says Kristen almost
stabbed rhaenyra in the face yeah that
was a bit of a close thing wasn't it
um did Kristen just put the sword
through the boar in such a way that
almost
um cut rhaenyra it's interesting seeing
the um bond between
Rainier and Kristen develop
um it's a little bit flirtatious like
there was a moment when uh Rainier asked
Kristen like oh you know so uh so you
single it's kind of like what she was
asking Kristen uh and Kristen said uh
yeah I had an adventurous youth uh but
never a formal betrothal so he was just
sort of bragging about like yeah yeah I
[ __ ] is what Kristen was saying um so
you know I think there's definitely some
sexual tension here
um there's also a bit of tension between
like rhaenyra and Daemon on um in
episode one when he was like putting the
necklace on her and stuff because you
know obviously one of the plot points
here is that viserys is trying to get
Rainier to marry somebody and so he uh
suggests that Lord Jason Lannister the
Lord of casterly rock the ancestor of
Tywin and Cersei and Jamie and Tyrion
um maybe Rainier should marry him yeah
that would make the Lannisters you know
allies of the throne which would be
great
um alongside you know the valerians and
the high Towers the Lannisters are I
think the second most wealthy house in
the realm behind the valerions uh and I
I found Jason's like arrogant uh
courtship quite funny like he really
just walks up and says hey girl I got a
lot of money I got some real good wine I
could build a kennel for your dragons
cause I got a lot of money and like he
just has this blunt arrogance and you
sort of get the sense that uh Jason's uh
moves uh have worked for him in the past
because everyone he's met before now has
been less rich and powerful than him but
for the first time in his life he's he's
trying to hit on someone who actually is
in a higher social class than he is
rhaenyra is a princess which is you know
even higher than than him as Lord and
all of a sudden when he hasn't got like
a status Advantage Rainier is not
impressed by his uh blustering uh brags
um so I quite enjoyed her rejecting him
um
but uh but yeah in the books they talk a
lot about how you know both Jason and
his twin brother Thailand uh were trying
to uh woo rhaenyra by giving her lots of
gifts uh they mention uh Blackwood and a
Bracken fighter duel for Rainier's hand
uh maybe this stuff will happen in the
future so I won't spoil anything but um
you know lots of people want to hook up
with Rainier because she's the princess
uh thanks for the Super Chat from El
Diablo who says Daemon going Rambo made
me LOL I thought it was a little bit
over the top like I I thought it was
sort of fitting for daemon's character
that he would you know misuse a peace
Banner he would betray the triarchy like
he does this dishonorable balls out
almost suicidal thing I think that kind
of works but I thought it was a bit
silly how like the treyarchy and the
crab feeder they sent like three dudes
at a time for a while
like like they're like let's send three
guys to kill Daemon and then he kills
them then then they're like yeah let's
send another three guys to kill Daemon
it's like why don't they just send all
their guys at once I mean I guess the
idea is that the the triarchy men are
afraid that karaxis is Gonna Come and
burn them all so I guess that makes
sense like they're really reluctant to
go out and fight him but it's like why
don't they just stay in their caves then
or just like I don't know and and you
know so many arrows missed Daemon like
there were all these guys shooting
arrows and and most of them like they
all missed until like quite a while in
but um yeah in terms of like daemon's
character I think it makes sense that
that he's just he's Bull's out
um he's got almost a suicidal belief in
his ability to kill everybody and it
worked for him it paid off like that's
what I think is significant like they
talk in the inside the episode The
Creator said that Daemon has really like
come out of this reforged into like a
new man he's reborn and I think that you
know part of it is that he did this
crazy violent Reckless dishonorable
Thing by by misusing a peace banner and
attacking and doing this crazy thing and
it worked for him it paid off he got
validation he got Victory by doing the
crazy thing so I think we can expect
Damon to be even more like balls out and
violent in the future because it worked
for him this time you know
thanks to Super Chat from dadrian and
from unsourced who says so Kristen and
rhaenyra are totally going to have a
torrid affair right well look I mean
once you've once you've killed a boar
together
um you've really just become intimate by
virtue of um slaying a ball haven't you
um what happens in the Kingswood stays
in the Kingswood you know thanks for the
Super Chat from Sam who says who were
the other dragons and their Riders So
currently the dragon riders in this
world are let me pull up the family tree
for you
um so originally King viserys had the
dragon balerion but balerion died uh
princess rhaenys Targaryen has the
dragon melis the Red Queen we have not
seen melis yet the new dragon we saw
this episode was Lenor valerion's Dragon
called sea smoke that was the dragon
that saved uh Daemon during the battle
um this is sea smoke
which is a very lovely silvery colored
Gray colored Dragon uh and obviously uh
rhaenyra has the dragon Cyrax the yellow
dragon and Daemon Targaryen has the red
dragon karaxis the squeaky snakey penis
necked one
um and so far that's yeah that's all the
dragon Riders isn't it it's rainy's with
melis it's Lenor with sea smoke
and it's Rainier with Cyrax but there
are a bunch of other dragons like
there's at least like a dozen a dozen
other dragons that are living in the
dragon pit or our hatchlings and you
know they've been ridden by like
previous generations of targaryens like
King jahiris's Dragon Verma Thor the
bronze Fury is a big old Dragon who's
who's still around and Alison's Dragon
Silver Wing
um and they mentioned a dream fire so
there are lots of dragons that are
around uh that we you know maybe we'll
see them in the future and also Lane of
the larion was asking about Vega which
is the biggest toughest dragon in the
world which is currently sitting on a
beach in Florida
thanks for the Super Chat from bandywine
who says best episodes so far dripping
with atmosphere and George's touch I'm
surprisingly endeared to Lionel strong
who was actually giving viserys prudent
and sincere advice yeah I mean it seems
like Lionel is the one guy who actually
is just not biased like Otto wants his
grandson aegon on the throne and Corliss
wants his grandchildren on the throne if
um you know someone marries a valerion
whereas Lionel is saying no like don't
marry my children I don't want to join
the royal family marry the valerians
because that's best for you you know so
it seems as though Lionel actually has
the Royal Family's interests at heart or
maybe Lionel has cordless interests at
heart we've never seen like a
conversation between Carlos and Lionel
but I wonder if there might be a
connection like a reason why Lionel is
sort of advocating the interests of uh
the valerions thanks for the Super Chat
from Alex who said says how many bad
Omens can one king have yeah yeah it's
not good it's not good you know he's
baby Balon died and he's and he the the
deer and uh the the stolen dragon egg
and uh there's a lot that's gone wrong
thanks to the Super Chat from uh Eliza
bitty who says I find it interesting
that viserys lost two fingers and he
also lost two of his closest counsel
Daemon and Corliss yeah that's a cool
Point like at the same time that you
know parts of viserys's body are falling
off uh his allies and his family are
falling off from him like rhaenyra is it
seems to be you know more distant from
him and like Corliss and Daemon have
left so yeah like like he he's falling
to pieces and his family is falling to
pieces at the same time
like it was interesting how you know
like Alison gave viserys this mended
dragon statue which is like maybe Alison
can glue things together but it seems
like the opposite is happening it seems
as though Alison is um part of the
problem in that this you know Hightower
versus rhaenyra Rift is is opening up
thanks for the Super Chat from Betsy who
says thanks for taking us back to the
best English class Vibes with Game of
Thrones raise your hand if you have a
question class thanks for the Super Chat
from Stefan who says I thought Daemon
was badass but I wanted to see a 1v1
against the crab feeder how was he able
to kill him in the dark caves on his
Turf yeah well now that you say that
like they they could have done some like
cool thing where like Daemon is you know
creeping through the dark caves and
maybe the crab feeder has like traps and
things and ambushes planned to kill
Daemon I think that given what we what
little we know about the crab feeder it
would it would be cool if he was like
setting traps and using his home turf
and uh yeah maybe they could have done
something cool with the crab feeder but
I think in terms of like a 1v1 fight
like at least from the crab feeder's
appearance like he doesn't look strong
he doesn't look tough he's riddled with
disease like I think Daemon would
absolutely butcher this guy as he did so
yeah I don't I'm not too mad about not
seeing a fight thanks to the Super Chat
from Andre who says could you talk more
about the Lannister guy who viserys was
trying to marry Rainier off to yeah so
this this guy is Lord Jason Lannister
and he has a twin called tibble
Lannister
um and they're rich they're Lannisters
they're crafty they're scheming there
isn't really much description of them in
the books that I can tell you about
um but they will have a role in in the
future I can tell you that the
Lannisters have a sort of interesting
history in um Fire and Blood the book
that this is based on
um so it was very interesting that Jason
Lannister said here hey by the way I
have a whole bunch of money uh I could
build a dragon pit in casterly rock and
what is what he means by that is that if
Rainier marries Jason Lannister and
moves to casterly rock uh Rainier could
house her Dragon Cyrax at casterly Rock
and that itself is sort of an
interesting power play for House
Lannister saying hey we could have
dragons at Castle Lannister could have
dragons because like you know if Jason
Lannister married rhaenyra and had
children
um those children could be Dragon Riders
right like just in the same way that
Lenor valerion is a non-targaryen dragon
rider because he has Targaryen blood
from rhaenys uh maybe there could be a
Lannister Dragon Rider if Rainier are
married Jason Lannister that would be
crazy and that would make the Lannisters
so much more powerful if they had
dragons
um it would also probably make the realm
a lot more unstable because the more
families there are with with Dragons the
more potential for you know terribly
disruptive Wars um and and that is
something that happened previously in
the book Fire and Blood so like
a couple of generations ago King
Harris's sister rhaenys uh Rayna sorry
Rayna Targaryen
um had a bit of a uh difficult
relationship with King maegor the cruel
and so she sort of fled and she lived in
the West in the Westlands for a while
she lived on this island called Fair
Isle and she had her Dragon there dream
fire the same dragon that was mentioned
uh previous episode
um and eventually she left Fair Isle
because the famines were annoyed that
the dragon was eating all of their sheep
and Rayna and dreamfire stayed at costly
Rock So Castle Iraq has hosted a dragon
before and the Lord at the time I think
was Lord Lyman Lannister was saying hey
Reina like you should totally marry my
son you should totally you know hang out
with us Lannisters uh you know and by
the way I noticed that your dragon has
been laying all these eggs maybe you
could give me one of those eggs you know
as a present since I've been such a good
host you should totally give a dragon to
the Lannister is yeah that'd be great
and you know reyno was like no like no
I'm not going to give you a dragon I'm
not gonna marry your son a because I'm
gay and B because I'm not going to give
a dragon to the Lannisters
um but we talk a little bit about this
story in uh the what's west of Westeros
I'll choot x video which is about Alyssa
farman and Rayna and the affair
um but yeah so my point is that the
Lannisters in the book have a history of
trying to get marriages and power and
Dragons from the targaryens and I think
we're seeing a continuation of that now
um and uh and yeah like one of the
things that the book says is that you
know the Lannisters they were Kings ones
because you know all of the different
kingdoms that existed before before
aegon the Conqueror turned up before
aegon the Conqueror came and conquered
Westeros and made it into one realm
there were hundreds of Kingdoms in
Westeros like they talk about Seven
Kingdoms
um but you know even before that there
were just lots of small Petty Kings lots
of little warring
um uh lordlings and kingdoms and and the
Lannisters were one of the most powerful
Kings in their area at one point and at
one point they were the kings of the
Westlands the kings of The Rock and it
was aegon who came along and ended that
and made them into Lords instead made
all of the great Lords bow to him but
the point is that you know the
Lannisters they were King's ones not all
that long ago it was like a hundred
years ago the Lannisters were Kings and
they didn't have to bow to anyone and I
think that at this point there is still
some ambition where they would like to
return to that level of Power by getting
Dragons by marrying into the Targaryen
Throne by the time of Game of Thrones
you know the memory of dragons the
memory of independent kingship is a
little bit more distant and faded but uh
it was only it was only a few
Generations ago that these Lords were
Kings
thanks for the Super Chat from Darth
Cruz who says please talk about sea
smoke there isn't a whole lot to say
about sea smoke I think sea smoke is a
is a young dragon like a hatchling
Dragon lane or valerion is the first
Rider of sea smoke
um so it's a young dragon it's said to
be quite a beautiful dragon with its
sort of smoky gray color
um and Lenor has been riding it since a
very young age
um in the books
um and you know that's part of why Lenor
was relevant in the Harren Hall Council
like in the TV show The Harren Hall
Council they were mostly talking about
uh rainey's Targaryen or viserys
Targaryen that was like the two main
candidates to become the heir to the
throne of the harrenhall council in
episode one but in the book Lenor
valerion reinis's son uh was the main
candidate not rhaenys uh partly because
Lenor was a dragon rider I had see smoke
whereas viserys didn't have a dragon
because valerion was dead
but you know lane or at the time was
like seven years old so they didn't want
a seven-year-old to be air so that's
part of why he wasn't chosen
uh but yeah there's not a whole lot that
I can say about sea smoke in the books
as yet thanks for the Super Chat from
Dopey Dragon who says I feel like lanor
being a dragon rider was not really
given much time or weight before we just
see him blasting uh being a writer
should be a big deal it should be a big
deal it should be a big deal
um I mean that that is one of the things
that makes the valerions so important I
mean like you know I guess I've said in
the past that you know viserys has to
marry someone and you know the
hightowers are good allies and the
valerians are good allies so you know I
either one is reasonable but yeah I
agree like the fact that the valerians
have two dragons Lenor has sea smoke and
rainy says melis the fact that the
valerians have two dragons like half the
dragon riders in the world are valerians
not targaryens alongside you know Daemon
and rhaenyra so um it really should be a
huge concern and a huge consideration
that hey we need to be friends with the
valerians we need to marry them into the
the royal family because if we have
dragon Riders who are pissed off at us
and who are not on our side we have a
huge [ __ ] problem I mean like the Hop
that's the whole thing like Targaryen
dominance comes from their dragons and
right now the valerians have as many
dragons as the targaryens do so the
valerians are potentially an enormous
threat that could Wipe Out the dogarians
potentially right now and I agree they
really should be talking about that that
really should be a concern
viserys's choice to marry Allison not
not uh uh not Elena uh was probably a
massive [ __ ] up because he
forgot about dragons thanks for the
Super Chat from quoth The Raven thanks
for the Super Chat from Emily who says I
felt like the deer who is screaming and
restrained and sacrificed in the name of
viserys's son reminded him of Emma uh I
think that's a great Point Emily I think
you're right like the way that he yeah I
think that's a fantastic parallel
because he really thinks about he's like
oh I've got to make the decision to
slaughter this deer just like in season
one episode one when viserys was told
hey uh you need to kill Emma now we need
to cut Emma open and get the baby out
which was
um this moment here
and yeah it felt like this sacrifice
that viserys was making we must
sacrifice my wife to birth a baby and
yeah it's a similar moment here with the
deer where you know the choice is
presented to him they had the deer all
tied up for him just like Emma was held
down when she was cut open
so yeah I I agree I think that's a
really good parallel thanks for the
Super Chat from Alexander who says I was
surprised what a loser Lord Lannister
was
have you ever met a billionaire before I
think there's a kind of um arrogance and
entitlement that
um makes very wealthy and privileged
people unable to relate to others like
the way that
um Jason Lannister he like Snapped his
fingers to make someone uh bring him
wine
um he just snapped his fingers and and
it appeared and he did not even like
acknowledge the person who brought him
home I mean like you know I guess that's
just normal for all these Lords and
things but but you know in this case I
think it really highlighted his
arrogance and douchiness the Lannisters
are kind of historically giant douches I
mean one of the sort of most unrealistic
things about Game of Thrones is that you
know the Starks have kind of always been
Stern and honorable and the Lannisters
have kind of always been cunning and
ambitious and uh [ __ ] and blonde
um like there are certain personality
traits and like you know the baratheons
tend to be
fiery Warriors and very masculine and
very you know uh prone to bouts of rage
and emotion
there is there is a certain like common
personality that has stayed the same
over like hundreds of years of History
like not to mention the Lannisters have
somehow like stayed blonde this whole
time it's like aren't they marrying
other families it's not like that like
the targaryens are incestuous
um like if you look at the genetics you
know the genetics of the targaryens is
ridiculous because since they keep
marrying their siblings like viserys is
like 50 percent
uh anis's genetics and 50 uh a list of
alaragon's genetics because they haven't
like like he he only has one set of
great grandparents you know like he
doesn't have 16 different
great-grandparents he has two
great-grandparents because of the incest
The Sibling incest uh my point is that
you know for for anyone other than the
targaryens it seems ridiculous that they
look the same and have the same
personality After All These Years anyway
thanks to the Super Chat from Charmander
master who says I liked rhaenys and
Allison playing tug of war with the
minstrel as a symbol for how Royals
fighting hurts the common person uh yeah
I I agree I mean I think part of uh the
point of that was that it showed how
rhaenyra was saying I'm the princess so
you have to obey me so I want you to
keep playing whereas Allison said but
I'm the queen and I want you to go away
and they sort of had this back and forth
where it's like you know listen to me no
listen to me and in the end the minstrel
listened to Alison uh because Allison is
the queen and the queen apparently
outranks the princess and so that just
shows how
um despite the fact that rhaenyra is out
of the throne despite the fact that
she's the firstborn daughter of the king
uh Alison is the one who has power you
know and that seems to that seems to
contradict the fact that you know all
these Lords they they bowed to Rainier
or they swore to obey Rainier as Heir
and Yet Alison is the one they are
following and so it's sort of this
undercurrent of despite what everyone
says baby aegon is seen as the heir
because he's male
um so yeah I I agree that was fine and
yeah like the long-suffering common man
who has to obey the whims of these uh
you know teen ages and these drunk Lords
and all these [ __ ] just because
they're Highborn thanks for the Super
Chat from Universe of Thrones I don't
know why the Targaryen sigil has four
legs I'm not sure if it really means
much the showrunner says that it
connects to Daenerys he used a
four-legged Dragon sometimes I don't
know if it's a big deal thanks for the
Super Chat from Evan who says it was
awesome to see viserys take a stand
against that Lannister it proves that he
really does care about rhaenyra I mean
you know it was it was words wasn't it
um because yeah there was a conversation
between uh Jason Lannister and viserys
where viseris sort of like you know
corrected Jason and said No like
rhaenyra is my Heir not aegon
um and yeah it was nice to see him stick
up for Rainier but I mean I think he
needs to be a bit more
uh loud and direct about telling
everyone that like I mean I mean the the
way that viserys was just sort of like
riling up Jason reminded me a lot of
Lancel and Robert in season one of Game
of Thrones
um like remember when Robert Baratheon
was drunk and he was just having an
enormous amount of fun
um talking [ __ ] Atlanta Lannister like
it was the same situation it was a drunk
king
um well this was at a tournament not a
hunt but you know he was just talking
[ __ ] out of Lannister
um because he was he had a lot of
feelings and he was drunk a very similar
scene here
uh thanks for the Super Chat from quoth
who says I feel like this was better
than the battle of the bastards I would
have loved seeing Jon disempower Ramsay
and drag out his corpse it was pretty
metal the way Daemon dragged the crab
feeder's corpse around yeah
um yeah I think it looks pretty good I
mean I I didn't love how over the top it
was that Daemon like single-handedly
killed like 20 dudes he somehow dodged
like a hundred arrows before two arrows
hit him and after two arrows hit him he
didn't seem to care anymore and also
like is this Arrow did that Arrow just
go through his breastplate just punch
through the metal god damn but then he
like plucked them out yeah I don't know
like I guess we got to suspend our
disbelief but it sort of reminds me in a
bad way of um Jon Snow at the start of
the battle of the bastards like I
remember when he was standing in front
of the cavalry charge he's just like
facing it alone and then he he got he
went through this crazy sequence where
all these people threw themselves at him
and he dodged all these arrows it did
feel very reminiscent of that and like
personally I like it when the violence
is just a little bit more subdued and a
little more realistic feeling
um like I don't like it when the
characters survive crazy odds over and
over because it feels like they have
plot armor and I like it when Game of
Thrones is a story where the heroes can
die you know where [ __ ] up does lead
to death sometimes but you know maybe
we'll see that in the future uh thanks
for the Super Chat from tin and from
Gabriella who says just to remind the
chat that targaryens are not immune to
grayscale because Miguel Targaryen died
of grayscale yeah so there is this thing
about
um targaryens being resistant to disease
this is a image of Miguel by Sophia a
goal of Nova and there is this idea that
targaryens don't get sick
um
which is not true all of the time the
targaryens seem to think that targaryens
never get sick but sometimes they do
that there was this plague that killed
King daeron the second
um and a bunch of people uh several
plagues have killed a bunch of
targaryens and that includes yeah
grayscale so Miguel was one of the
daughters of King jahiris and Queen
Elizabeth Queen elisane Targaryen and
she died of grayscale because she became
a scepter she became like a nun and she
was caring for some people who were sick
with grayscale and she caught grayscale
from the patient and died so uh yeah
targaryens do seem to tend to be
resistant to disease a lot of the time
but they're not totally resistant to
disease it's a little bit like you know
targaryens do seem to be a little bit
resistant to heat and fire in the books
but they are not totally immune to fire
like Daenerys gets burned in the books
whereas in the TV show it seems as
though at least in the original TV show
The seems as though targaryens at least
an aristargaryen is totally immune to
fire in the show
thanks for Super Chat from Gandalf who
says isn't shireen's grayscale cured by
Lords Stannis summoned from across
Westeros uh in the TV show yes in the
books they didn't say that they did
anything special like in the books there
are forms of grayscale that just
naturally stop and don't kill you it
usually affects children specifically
um and there's different forms some of
them kill you some of them don't
um I mean in the behind the scenes stuff
last episode they said that
um crab feeder's grayscale is
progressing you know I mean it seems as
though the reason why crab feeder wears
this mask
is to sort of hide the gross grayscale
stuff it's interesting that one of crab
feeder's eyes looks kind of foggy as
though maybe that eye has gone blind
um because grayscale does eventually
make you blind
um it's really nasty great scale like
there's one of um
one of euron and Balon greyjoys uh
Brothers got grayscale and there's this
really horrible description
um in the book of uh how this this child
was was slowly dying from the grayscale
and like couldn't
um couldn't move or do anything anymore
but he was still alive and he was still
breathing bed bound and then euron
Greyjoy because you're on Greyjoy is the
most horrifying evil character in the
books euron Greyjoy came and just like
pinched his brother's nose shut because
he's like mouth was like grayscaled
clothes and he was mostly stoned but he
was still breathing through his nose and
euron just came along and pinched his
brother's nose shut so that he like
suffocated to death and asphyxiated
um while he was incapacitated by the
grayscale and then euron said that he
went and pissed into the sea and he
cursed the gods and he said if the if
the gods are real then kill me for the
crime of killing my brother because
kinslaying is a horrible crime but the
gods did not strike year on down so he
figures that since he could kill his
brother with grayscale then he can do
whatever he likes he'll do any blasphemy
if that if God won't stop him he'll be
his own God and you can watch The euron
Graduate video about by old shift X if
you want to know more about euron
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Victor
uh yeah no targaryens are not immune to
grayscale Miguel got it thanks for the
Super Chat from Brian who says did we
talk about how cilia it was when Daemon
soloed like 20 dudes I agree I think
that was silly uh that there is uh
artwork in the Fire and Blood book that
shows
um Daemon killing kragas uh in the book
they say that Daemon Targaryen beheaded
crackers crab feeder with a swing of his
Blade Dark sister so this this is what
it looks like in the illustrations in
the book Daemon killing the crab feeder
so you'll notice that in the book crab
feeder does not have a sons of the harpy
mask he does not have grayscale I mean
the whole war is described in like a
couple of paragraphs like we don't get
details the details are created by the
show thanks for the Super Chat from Jess
who says do you think the show will
reach the end of Fire and Blood no
because Fire and Blood covers 130 years
of history from aegon the Conqueror
until some other characters
um it covers many kings many years and I
I think that this show House of the
Dragon I mean it starts in chapter 12 of
Fire and Blood Heirs of the Dragon
and I think that it will end around
chapter or like 15 or something
um which is you know I'm not going to
spoil anything but like the current
story ends around like chapter 19 18 or
19. and then there are a few more
chapters after that about some other
stuff I I don't think that this show
will cover the book all the way to the
end I think it'll only cover chapters
like 12 to 19 probably and they say that
they'll they're going to do that in like
three or four seasons total but they've
also said that you know if House of the
Dragon is a success they might cover
other historical periods so you know we
were talking about the blackfires before
it would be extremely cool
um if House of the Dragon did a few
seasons to tell the story of the
blackfyre rebellions
um or maybe they could tell the story of
aegon's conquest or Robert's Rebellion
or you know that there are lots of other
historical periods they could cover
um and I hope that we'll get to see them
because there's some really cool other
stories and I think you know I'm shocked
by how good house of the Dragon is I was
a little bit worried that as the dragon
might be bad but so far I I think it is
doing a really good job and it's staying
very close to the books but it's also
adding a lot and I think that they're
making really good choices I think that
Ryan Condell and George R Martin who
co-created this show I think they've
done a really good job so far
I think that probably my least favorite
thing about this show so far is the
aegon's prophecy dream thing
um I think that that
takes away some of the mystery and I
think that it sort of changes the moral
meaning of this story
um like I think the this story as it's
written in the book it's sort of about
the Perils of ambition and power and
drama and just hate and love and
rivalries and feelings and and lust and
um I think that by making it about
saving the world from Frosty Darth Maul
instead uh I think that sort of changes
the meaning in a way that sort of
undermines the point but I mean you know
we're only three episodes in so it
remains to be seen
um what the sort of meaning will be in
the end thanks for the Super Chat from
Carlos who says rewatched Game of
Thrones a few days ago but the world in
Hot D feels bigger is it the power of
budget or better decisions by the
showrunners I mean we talked before
about how like you know Robert Baratheon
going on a royal hunt in season one
um involved you know four Dudes walking
in single file in a forest with a spear
uh whereas this Royal Hunt is hundreds
of people and horses and dogs and and
you know uh and yeah I think the reason
for that is budget but I think that you
know happily it it does fit the theme
Ryan Condell keeps going on about the
decadence of this time
the royal family is way more powerful
and Rich and influential
now than it is at the time of Game of
Thrones I mean that's sort of throughout
even in the books you know there's a
sense that
um the past was glorious and great and
big and now things have declined like
all those big castles like Storm's end
and Harren Hall and and the wall all
these great monuments they were built in
the past they no longer have the power
and the technology to do these things
there's an almost post-apocalyptic Vibe
and also just like emotionally and
socially like so many of the characters
like Ned Stark and Paris and sell me
that they think of the Robert's
Rebellion era as being a better time you
know things were better back then and
now everything's more corrupt
everything's more Petty everything's
more small scale
um and you know I think this this is
going back and it's showing us when
times were good it's showing us when the
Splendor existed it's showing us what we
lost
uh co-creator Ryan condle compared it to
Star Wars when like in the Star Wars
original trilogy we hear about the Jedi
and Obi-Wan says man the Clone Wars they
sure were a crazy time you know the the
lightsaber is uh uh An Elegant weapon
for uh for a for a more civilized time
is that the line Obi-Wan says in Star
Wars
um and then in the Star Wars prequels we
go back and we get to actually see what
that Great era looked like we get to see
what it looked like when there were
hundreds of Jedi instead of just a few
like the targaryens are like the Jedi
because in the main Game of Thrones show
there's only Daenerys and viserys
there's only a couple of targaryens left
whereas in the past there were lots just
like the Jedi when we go back and see
the height of the Jedi
um and of course you know it might make
some people a little worried to hear the
creators of House of the Dragon compare
their story to the Star Wars prequels
because a lot of people don't like the
Star Wars prequels um but I think that
so far the Game of Thrones prequel is
doing better than the Star Wars prequels
were at least in my opinion uh thank you
for the Super Chat from where's poochie
who says what is up with the CGI
different company yeah I I was again I
was not loving some of the CGI I think
like the boar specifically
just sort of this brown blur that flew
in and you know knocked Kristen Cole's
Sky High
um in a way that I feel should have
broken at least some of his bones
um that they seem to be sort of trying
to keep the CGI off screen as much as
possible and yeah there was also you
know the CGI idea which looked okay I
guess some of the dragon flame honestly
I think is not great some of the dragon
flame looks
um like it was sort of
um it just doesn't look like it's really
the but uh you know maybe that's just me
I think it's I think it's okay
thanks for the Super Chat from
JM who says viserys is neat different
portrayal of a bad King in Game of
Thrones we had Bobby B who never went to
a small council meeting uh viserys
dutifully attends every meeting but
makes bad choices yeah so like viserys
as described in Fire and Blood
seems a bit more like Bobby B
um this is the main illustration of King
viserys Patty considine this is him in
the Fire and Blood illustration by Doug
Wheatley and you know he is portrayed
more as a indulgent Drinker eater Padia
um he's more like Bobby B the books say
that viserys like mostly left the
governance of the realm to his hand Otto
so it is a change that in the show
viserys is much more involved and much
more active and he clearly really cares
about trying to do the right thing he
just is not making great decisions or at
least he's not like following through
enough on his decisions he's sort of
compromising too much is I think
viserys's problem
um and yeah I think that that it's good
that they've changed him like that to
make him more distinct from the way he
is in the book which is I think perhaps
too similar to Robert Baratheon
thanks for the donation from James who
says I really like this episode but I
wish we got a bit more reaction to
Hobart shouting basically treason by
declaring aegon's second of his name
yeah it's a good point so so you know we
had the scene where baby aegon turned up
to the hunt uh and yeah Hobart Hightower
here he is he says aegon the Conqueror
babe second of his name and I think you
know traditionally formally properly you
only call someone aegon II aegon the
third viserys the first of viserys II
you only say the number when they're
king
um because you know there have been many
aegons
um like Anis Targaryen King Annie's
Targaryen had a aegon a child called
aegon
um who was called aegon the uncrowned
and aegon the uncrowned he wasn't called
aegon II because he was never king
um and you know there were stillborns
and stuff who were named aegon but they
die so you only get you only get a
number you only get called the second or
the third when you become king and yeah
I agree Hobart saying that aegon is the
second that is like saying he is the
king despite the fact that rhaenyra is
the named Heir so yeah that's a little
bit treasonous I would think but you
know maybe you can just say it like a
joke and that's that's sort of how
politics works you know you just you
just say the thing that you want to
happen until it comes true if enough
people believe something if enough
people say something it becomes true
because you know kingship is not a real
physical thing it's just the fact that
everyone believes that they're the king
and um you know public opinion and the
way that public opinion is expressed is
one of the themes of Fire and Blood I
think so
I will say more of this uh thanks for
the Super Chat from Robbie and tulsey
and k k r l who says you can see
viserys's missing fingers in The
Hungover scene when he's sipping from
the Gold Cup yeah do we want to have a
look at viserys's missing fingers yeah
yeah you're right there we go he's got a
couple of stumps there I wonder if the
um rot will continue to progress what is
this tiny little cup that viserys is
drinking from is that coffee what is it
that he's drinking I don't know maybe
he's uh taken some shots hair at the dog
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Henry
who says condo insists on calling
viserys the king of the Rhino maybe it's
a Taiwan Chinese Taipei situation where
they don't want to admit they're
unconquered yeah so at this time Dawn is
not part of the Seven Kingdoms Dawn
which is where the martells and Ober and
Martel and Pedro Pascal are from they
are their own thing they are not ruled
by the King on the iron throne and yeah
so it is kind of weird
um that they say uh that they call the
king they call King viserys King of the
rhoynara and the first man and the Rhino
are an ethnic group who live in Dawn so
king viserys is not really the king of
the Rhino but I guess you know like I
was just saying like you know you you s
you say something is true enough and
once enough people believe it then it
becomes the truth you know um so if you
just say that yeah we are totally in
charge of dawn that's that's kind of the
first step in making it true sometimes
but um but yeah Dawn remains unconquered
and will remain unconquered for this
whole show uh it's only later on through
marriage and diplomacy that Dawn gets
brought into the realm and and you know
the Rhino by the way are nymeria's
people princess nymeria who was talked
about in season one episode one
um she was the leader of the rhoynar
people and she led them on this big
migration
um and she is admired by rhaenyra and
she's a symbol of female power because
in Dawn
The Inheritance laws are different like
in most of Westeros the eldest male
inherits before the eldest female but in
Dawn uh it's just the eldest child so a
woman can inherit a lordship
um in front of her brothers in Dawn so
that's obviously a very relevant idea in
the dance of the Dragons when rhaenyra
is trying to inherit and that's relevant
in book four of feast of crows in the
main Game of Thrones series because
there's a character called Ariane Martel
who crowns Marcella Baratheon and tries
to make her the queen of Westeros using
dornish inheritance law because you know
messella is in Dawn and Ariane says they
should follow dornish law and trust
their style of war with the Lannisters
by crowning Miss Ella
um anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Nicholas who says I think Strong's move
was to get viserys to intervene in the
stepstones lest Krabby Patty murk the
valerion kid okay yeah that's an
interesting thought um because yeah like
I think Lionel was one of the people
telling viserys hey you should probably
like send help I mean I think Alison was
the one who convinced viserys to send
reinforcements to the um Daemon and
valerions but yeah I mean the fact that
they well yeah you made a good point
yeah we have to pray that lane or
valerion doesn't get killed in this war
Lionel said yeah you're right
um and yeah obviously Rainier can't
marry Lenor if Lenor gets eaten by crabs
can he so yeah I guess that's part of
why visera sent reinforcements was that
he might be taking this idea of marrying
Rainier at Elena seriously
um so that's why he sent them Aid
perhaps it's going to be funny when
those reinforcements arrive at the
stepstones and find that you know the
war is already over or maybe it won't be
I mean maybe the world will continue
even without the crowd Theta we will
have to find out
thanks to the Super Chat from Liam who
says why isn't the north of the realm
talked about in House of the Dragon it
feels as if it doesn't exist in this
show compared to Game of Thrones the the
north always has been sort of its own
thing like unlike Dawn the north is part
of the realm it is ruled by the king but
you'll notice that the north is
very far away this whole chunk here is
the north it it's almost as big as the
rest of Westeros combined the north is
huge and there aren't many people in it
and it doesn't have much money and it
doesn't have much crops it doesn't have
many nights like the north is mostly
irrelevant to the South like the South
sort of does its own thing they're all
close to each other they can communicate
and travel around really quickly whereas
you know just like just just like
sending someone to go and visit the
stocks takes weeks and weeks
um so the north has always kind of been
separate and the reason why the Starks
are relevant in the time of Game of
Thrones is because they come South you
know it's because the Starks come down
uh to King's Landing and travel all that
way that they become relevant to the to
the Royal goings-on
um it's not like in the Game of Thrones
show when people are just teleporting
and Jet packing back and forth between
the North and South the north is very
isolated in the books so it kind of
makes sense I mean it was funny
um that what was it rickon Stark they
called him in uh house of the Dragon
episode one like he turned up to swear
loyalty to Rainier and he looks quite
grumpy doesn't it doesn't he and you
would be because he just traveled like
weeks and weeks just to come down and to
kneel to Rainier and then turn around
and go home right you would be a bit
peeved if you had to come all that way
just to say yep I'll support you uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Brian who
says I don't like how they made Rainier
the protagonist instead of being gray
like in the books uh it seems weird to
make the uh allisonton auto side more uh
villainous I I kind of disagree because
I feel like you know like Rainier
especially in this episode yeah I agree
that she comes off as the product us
like we are meant to sympathize for her
but I think that both Alison and
rhaenyra you know have their good sides
and their bad sides like I think that
rhaenyra is a sympathetic protagonist in
this episode but like she also is kind
of a dick like she's not making it easy
for anyone
um and you know she's not even making
smart decisions really I mean I I feel
like a large part of why Rainier wants
to be the heir to the throne is because
most people don't want her to be the
head of the throne know what I mean like
viserys says in this episode if I told
rhaenyra that she's not allowed to marry
Jason Lannister she would want to marry
Jason Lannister like she's a she's a
teenager who just Rebels and wants to go
against whatever her parents are telling
her which is you know the way some
people are
um I I think that rhaenyra is kind of
being
um stubborn and annoying um you know
realistic and you know I think I think
it's perfectly good writing but I I
don't think that rhaenyra is like
totally the good guy and again like it's
kind of scary when she stabs the [ __ ]
out of that bore you know like she's
covered in blood
um and you know I also think Rainier is
still working out if she really wants to
be the heir or not you know like I think
that she has a lot of feelings and
frustration about her sort of alienation
and displacement but
I I don't think that it's as simple as
Rainier is the good guy and Alison is
the bad guy that's not the sense that I
get and Alison you know Alison tries to
reconcile with rhaenyra here like she's
saying it doesn't have to be like this
let's be friends again
um I think that Otto does come across as
villainous but I think Rainier and
Allison are both pretty sympathetic
thanks for the Super Chat from Alfred uh
I don't think Daemon will get grayscale
because grayscale can be dormant and
non-contagious like Shireen thanks for
the Super Chat from Source boss I agree
Jason Lannister's sassy finger snap was
very cool thanks for the Super Chat from
Brennan who says that a shady slightly
drunk character named alt schwift X said
he lifted this out of your wallet and I
wanted to return it thanks Brandon also
give Paddy considine all the awards yeah
I think viserys's Paddy coincidence
performance as viserys has been really
good
um because he is sort of just repeatedly
[ __ ] everything up but we feel so
sorry for him while he does it you know
um I mean you know I guess we can be
less sympathetic the more drunk he's
getting
um like it sort of feels like he's just
giving up on taking action sometimes
um like he sees how many problems he has
but he just he just wants to eat his
onions at the banquet instead
um all this [ __ ] politicking he said
so
yeah but it's a great performance thanks
for the Super Chat from Chris who says
that pug was a total Ed Sheeran moment
for me yeah what was more immersion
breaking the appearance of Ed Sheeran in
season seven episode one or the
appearance of the pug in this episode I
feel like the Pug was fine because like
in real you know royal families in in
any family sometimes people have pets
sometimes people have cherished cute
little Doggers I think that's I think
that's fine I think that's real
um I I I don't think it's ridiculous I
mean it's like the bloody bro the
British royal family and their little
pets
um I think it's perfectly fine to have a
dog uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Henrik who says who was the guy flying
the small Dragon at the end so that was
Lenor valerion and Lenor is the son of
uh Corliss valerion uh we saw Lenor uh
in episode one that's young Lenor and
Lenor has now grown up he's grown up
quite rapidly but this is lane or
valerion and his dragon is called sea
smoke and sea smoke is a young gray
Dragon quite a pretty dragon
um and it was Lenor and sea smoke who
came and saved Daemon in this battle
um and yeah thanks for the Super Chat
from Lizard who says shouldn't Daemon
attacking under a flag of Palais be as
controversial as the phrase breaking
guest rights uh it goes against custom
yes I think it is very bad that Daemon
used a Peace Flag and then killed
everyone because you know conventions of
War are there to make Wars less horrible
than they might otherwise be if you
can't trust your enemy to surrender when
they say they're surrendering then you
know next time you're just gonna
slaughter them instead right like if you
don't show Mercy to people who surrender
then no one's ever going to surrender
and Wars are never gonna end you know so
yeah it is [ __ ] up I mean maybe part
of why Daemon might get away with this
uh is that these guys are people from
the triarchy you know and I think a lot
of westerosi Lords westerosi people
don't have a lot of respect for like
Eastern people and their Customs it's a
different culture it's a different world
they don't exist in the same political
cultural structure so maybe you know
they don't respect the free cities
enough to feel the need to actually you
know obey their Customs but yeah I mean
it definitely does tell us that Daemon
is someone who is willing to break the
rules and we already knew that from when
we saw Daemon on the throne
in season one episode one
um and uh Harold westerling said you
know seven Hells what's he doing on the
bloody Throne
um it it it tells us something about the
character and he's someone who breaks
rules and is willing to cause a great
deal of trouble thank you for the Super
Chat from Ryan and from Cobalt who says
do you think Daemon isn't getting enough
credit among the fans as well as the
characters I mean look he I mean he's I
think he I think he has won some credit
he's won some glory for himself today I
think that people will be impressed with
Daemon for single-handedly slaying the
crab feeder and you know uh potentially
ending this war potentially
um I think that people will continue to
be annoyed by Daemon I mean I think that
the valerions might be very pleased with
Daemon for his assistance
um so maybe that Alliance and that
relationship will deepen
um
credit I mean yeah look I still think
Damon's kind of a [ __ ] because he
enjoys mutilating civilians but um
we'll see how that progresses thanks for
the Super Chat from Christian uh yes the
crab feeder did have grayscale thanks
for the Super Chat from Rudy who says
are they going to tell us more about the
Song of Ice and Fire prophecy or are
they just mentioning it to tie in the
story to got
yeah I'm very curious to see whether
they talk more about aegon the
conqueror's prophecy about the white
walkers I mean it's interesting like we
got talk uh this episode about viserys's
dream of having a son and then he
stopped believing in the dream and
that's why he named rhaenyra as Heir but
now that he has a son he has baby aegon
he sort of changed his mind again and
that's you know that that is very
consistent with dreams in the main
series uh because like maester Amon
Targaryen who we saw in the show he uh
was he he's a Targaryen and he had a
relationship with rhaegar Targaryen who
is the father of Jon Snow at least in
the TV show
um rhaegar Targaryen is this fella who
hooked up with lyanna Stark
um and rhaegar Targaryen had beliefs
about prophecy he believed that he was
the prince of the prince that was
promised who would defeat the White
Walkers and then he changed his mind and
he thought that his son aegon would be
the one who would defeat the white
walkers
and then he changed his mind again and
he ran off with lyanna Stark and had
babies and had Jon Snow and it seems as
though rhaegar thought that his son John
would be the one who would save the
world from the white walkers
um aegon's dream in House of the Dragon
is called The Song of Ice and Fire and
Jon Snow is symbolically of Ice and Fire
because the icy Starks and the fiery
targaryens are his parents
um so it seems as though in the books it
might be Jon Snow who is like the
prophesied one to save the world from
the white walkers
um my point is that you know rhaegar's
you know he sort of loses his faith he
changes his mind he has all these
different interpretations of the
prophecy you know aemon like aemon
changes his mind in book four and he
says oh you know what I think Daenerys
is the prince that was promised
um and you know Melisandre thinks that
Stannis is the prince that was promised
so there's all these different opinions
and interpretations and and it goes
along with the emotions of the
individual you know it's not all about
magic and rules and ancient Scrolls it's
about the feelings of the people like
rhaegar believed in himself but then he
believed in someone else and he fell in
love so it's all connected to
relationships and feelings and I think
that they perfectly captured that with
viserys
well you know it was so much about
viserys's love for Emma and then he lost
Emma and then he lost his faith and then
he started to believe in rhaenyra and he
had a closer relationship with rhaenyra
but then he he hooked up with Alison and
had a baby and that sort of shaken his
faith again so
um I think that's really it fits
wonderfully with how dreams are
portrayed in A Song of Ice and Fire it's
about your personal desires and dreams
because like it's not about magic it's
not just fantasy
um it's about real life and real life is
about having dreams and having desires
and sometimes you lose your dreams and
sometimes you gain your dreams and
people change your perspective on your
dreams and you know it's that that's why
this is about real human drama not just
dragons and tits and Dragons thanks for
the Super Chat from Daniel who says how
did Daemon fight with two arrows in his
chest yeah he seemed pretty chill about
the arrows like he sort of fell over and
looked upset about the arrows for a
little while but then he pulled the
arrows out and just continued running
and fighting so yeah like come on like
other uh did the arrows seriously hurt
him or not did the arrow did his armor
stop the arrows or not not super clear
thanks for the Super Chat from sitali
who says what is up with all the
pornographic orgy tapestries in the
castle love the channel you're the best
thank you sitlali yeah there are a lot
of those bloody tapestries aren't there
um we saw them in the scene with uh
Alison and uh Otto I'm not sure if I can
even Yeah well yeah I'm not I can't even
show them because YouTube is so uh
goddamn
um afraid of bodies
um but there are these these pictures of
people having sex all over the walls of
the red keep and some of them are humans
having sex with humans some of them have
dragons having sex with humans which
connects to the whole Blood Of The
Dragon idea that the targaryens are
connected to the dragons
um and you know I think that
symbolically it does make sense to me
that there's all this sex imagery
because you know it sort of mirrors the
blood imagery of the opening sequence
with the bloodline like dripping through
because it's all about death and life
and the interconnectedness of life and
death I mean season one episode one had
Emma dying in childbirth at the same
time that the men were killing each
other in the field like this whole
machine this whole political wheel it
grind remains over people life and death
birth and death
um and I think that having the sex
scenes uh is part of that it's sort of
the other side of the death
um and almost the almost like the
violence of the orgy as well it's quite
a quite a passionate orgy that's going
on in some of those scenes and the
violence of it you know again that
interconnectedness
um but I feel like it shouldn't be in
the background of every goddamn Scene It
feels like every second scene there's a
there's a you know uh orgy in the
background which just feels a little bit
silly and distracting when it's that
much but um I think thematically it
makes sense
thanks and also it's a horny story like
Fire and Blood is a very horny book
um and this show will continue to be
increasingly horny so I I guess that
makes sense in that respect thank you
for the Super Chat from Payton who says
Lionel strong giving good advice to his
King Shame he hasn't been listening yeah
I mean look I think that Lionel probably
is broadly right that that siding with
the valerians would be a good idea
because the valerians have two dragons
rhaenys rides melis and lane or ride sea
smoke but um
but uh yeah viserys just really wanted
to hook up with the teenage Alison
because she gave him Warhammer figurines
thanks for the Super Chat from cat and
from shampoo tester who says loved the
comment that Jay Harris's daughters
drove him mad yeah it's a great point so
you know we had some dialogue about how
viserys has so much trouble with his
daughter Rainier and uh King johera's
had even more trouble with his daughters
because he had about five of them or
something and you know Sarah Targaryen
ran off and had joined a brothel just to
spite him and
um Melissa was a tomboy and viscera was
a
narcissistic borderline personality
disorder nightmare
um Harris had very bad relationships
with some of his daughters some of them
died and you know alisane blamed ja
Harris for the death of his daughter
dayella because you know Alison feels
that J Harris pushed her into getting
married and having children too early
and dayella as it turns out became the
mother of Emma Aaron J Harris's daughter
dayella died giving birth to Emma and
then Emma died giving birth to uh the
baby Balon who died so there is a long
history of girls being chewed up and
spat out by this royal family
and viserys is not the first Targaryen
King to have difficulty with his
daughter and I think part of it is that
you know
the Targaryen girls are
more fiery because the targaryens have
these fiery personalities these
rebellious powerful personalities and
because targaryens can be dragon riders
that means that these girls have weapons
of war you know I mean part of how this
patriarchy works is that the women can't
wield swords the women can't fight in
battles and therefore they have to rely
on men but targaryens who have dragons
they don't need to rely on men for
protection or for war because they have
a goddamn Dragon so you know girls
having dragons is like a inherently a
threat to the patriarchy and I guess
that sort of fits with Otto's
personality because Otto you know he
calls Missouri a [ __ ] and he you know
wants his daughter Allison to go and
hook up with the King like he wants to
enforce this you know very traditional
gendered way of doing things and so you
know in last episode when rhaenyra
turned up on a dragon and like totally
disempowered Otto and totally stripped
Otto with his control of the situation I
think that's shows how you know someone
like Otto who wants uh this sort of
gendered order to be in place would hate
these girls running around on dragons or
running amok you know disrupting that
order
thanks for the Super Chat from tulsey
who says Daemon Rainier both got
physically covered in blood this episode
and viserys couldn't even make an easy
hunting kill all Targets get their hands
dirty and viserys continues to struggle
with power yeah I mean I think it was a
very deliberate
um
contrast to see yeah Daemon and Rainier
are getting out there and doing it and
you know getting into violence and being
competent whereas viserys spent almost
this entire episode sitting on his bum
drinking wine complaining eating and
then coming to slaughter like one deer
that was already tied up for him but he
[ __ ] it up and he had to stab it twice
which is it actually it's quite a lot
like remember Rob Stark executing
Rickard carstark uh in season three
episode five uh Rickard karstark is this
lord of the car Starks and he was pissed
off because some of his children were
killed and he wanted revenge on Jaime
Lannister but then Catelyn free Jaime
Lannister and Rickard was pissed off
Rickard had this lovely big beard and so
Rob Stark decided to execute Rickard for
going against his wishes
um which you know arguably was the right
thing to do but killing Rickard sort of
was a disaster because the car Stark
Army abandoned him and it created
dissension and it was sort of
part of the the downward spiral that led
to Rob's death at the Red Wedding um and
when Rob killed Rickard karstark he
actually no I think I'm misremembering
no yeah I am misremembering Rob killed
Rickard fine what I am thinking of is
Theon killing bloody Broderick uh castle
that's what I'm thinking of
uh
uh when Theon took over Winterfell in
season two and he executed
um he executed Roderick castle and when
Theon executed Roderick Castle he did a
really [ __ ] job of cutting off his head
he like had to take multiple blows and
he was like hacking the guy's head off
he didn't do it in one clean blow he had
to take multiple blows and I think that
was a symbol of theon's incompetence and
ugliness and just like the illegitimacy
of him being in charge if he can't even
cut a guy's head off correctly then how
is he gonna hold Winterfell you know
that was sort of the meaning there and I
think similarly the fact that viserys
could not cleanly kill this deer
shows how he's not capable of cleanly
being in charge and cleanly dealing with
the succession you know so yeah it's a
very bad Omen and certainly the
soundtrack and the whole vibe of that
scene contributed to that to that
feeling of oh no like this is not good
thanks for the donation from ranak who
says Jason Lannister hyping up costly
Rock just makes me more disappointed in
what we got yeah I totally agree I felt
the same way because like like Jason
Lannister the Lord of castly rock the
ancestor of Tywin and Jaime and Cersei
and Tyrion he was saying my house costly
rock is so big and so cool if you stand
on the top of the rock you can see
across the sea and here's some artwork
of what costly Rock looks like in the
books it is massive it is a Giant
Mountain and the casterlies and the
Lannisters they live inside it well not
the castle is anymore just the
Lannisters live inside it it's like this
network of caves this this like Palace
that they've made inside the um
inside the rock it's kind of funny that
there appear to be uh battlements on the
uh walls on the Rock I'm not sure what
the bloody point of battlements are when
it's like 400 feet in the air
what is the point of those battlements
are you gonna fire arrows on your
enemies from up here anyway um so castly
rock in the books is huge and impressive
and awesome whereas when we got to see
costly Rock in the TV show it was not
quite so big and awesome here's what it
looked like in season three episode
season seven episode three like Daenerys
and like gray worm like briefly took
costley Rock in season seven costly rock
is nowhere near as impressive in the
show compared to how it looks in the
books huh so uh yeah I mean that's what
that's sort of the curse of this show is
that however good house of the Dragon is
it's still in the shadow of the original
Game of Thrones show which you know
there were good things about the
original show especially the early
Seasons but a lot of people hated the
later Seasons
um and that's part of why I personally
don't like the aegon's dream thing in
season one episode one because it sort
of I don't want to be reminded of the
underwhelming end to the White Walker
plot line in season eight you know but
you know we'll see how it develops and
you know not everybody hated season
eight thank you for the Super Chat from
Miles who says maybe the crabs eat at
crab feeders grayscale to keep it
manageable now there's a good theory a
little bit like the maggots eating
viserys's rotted finger yeah maybe the
crabs nibble on crab feeders
um uh grayscale so that he doesn't die I
like that theory maybe the reason why
crab feeder makes all these people
getting eaten by crabs is just to you
know give them some a good skin care
routine you know just to get rid of
those those blackheads and dry skin with
some crabs he's just trying to help them
out thanks for the Super Chat from
Stuart who says this show can really go
on beyond the dance till up to and cover
Robert's Rebellion
I do not expect this show to cover the
like 180 years between now and Robert's
Rebellion like that I don't think they
need to cover all of it I mean I mean
look theoretically they could cover all
of Fire and Blood
um there's like a there's a period in
history after this conflict that they
could cover but I suspect that they're
just going to focus it on the dance of
the Dragons itself
um so I think just a few seasons thanks
for the Super Chat from Lamar who says
at the party was viserys Targaryen
carrying the same dagger that was the
one that killed the white walkers yes
viserys has been wearing this dagger uh
all throughout the show
um it's it's you can't yeah there it is
it's the uh quote unquote cats poor
dagger
so we first saw this uh in Game of
Thrones season one episode two when this
assassin was sent to kill Bran Stark and
Catelyn fought off the Assassin and it
was killed by the direwolf summer and in
the show they never actually explained
who sent this assassin and why in the
books they say that uh Joffrey sent the
Assassin to kill bran uh which seems
like it might have been a retcon it's
sort of a weird little mystery thing in
the books it's not a big deal but uh
this dagger was brought by Catelyn to
Varys and Littlefinger and Littlefinger
said that it was his dagger that was
taken by Tyrion and so this is the
reason why Catelyn arrested Tyrion which
sparked the entire war and then after
Ned fell Littlefinger had the dagger and
in season seven Littlefinger gave the
dagger to bran which is a really [ __ ]
dumb thing to do because the the knife
is a symbol of littlefinger's betrayals
and crimes and lies so so probably a
dumb idea to give that reminder of his
evil to bran the guy who can see the
future but you know season seven never
really made sense did it and then bran
gave the knife to Arya maybe because
bran knew the future and knew that this
was going to be the knife that would be
used to kill the night king and the
threat of the white walkers
so the constant presence of this knife
on viserys you know it shows that
viserys is constantly aware of his
responsibility to remember aegon's dream
so the targaryens can defeat the white
walkers
um which you know for us reminds us that
well it wasn't the targaryens who
defeated the white walkers like yes
Daenerys and Jon Snow who is also a
Targaryen at least in the show
um they were instrumental in bringing
together a coalition of forces to fight
against the White Walkers you know
without the targaryens maybe Arya never
would have got the chance to kill the
night king
um but you know it is sort of this weird
dissonance that like
viserys has this knife and this prophecy
about the Targaryen saving the world but
like we know that it's Arya so like how
how are those dots going to connect what
are they going to tell us in this show
that helps us understand what happened
there because I think you know in the
books
the ending with the white wall because
it is going to be very very different we
don't know exactly what's going to
happen but I I suspect based on a lot of
the foreshadowing that Jon Snow and
Daenerys in the books are going to have
a much bigger role in defeating the
white walkers
um I think there's big possibilities for
some kind of magical sacrifice some kind
of flaming sword called lightbringer
some kind of real like weird magic
intense stuff maybe bran will have a
psychic battle with the heart of Winter
maybe euron will be involved there is
some like real crazy dark high fantasy
Shenanigans happening in the books but
my point is that it's weird because this
show House of the Dragon is sticking
very close to the books in a lot of ways
whereas the Game of Thrones show did not
stick close to the books at all in the
later Seasons mostly because there
weren't books to stick to in the later
Seasons
um to be fair so
look the knife is a very weird thing
like it feels to me like a very awkward
mishmash of show cannon with this knife
because that knife is not significant in
the books like there is no like super I
mean you know in the books at the moment
Littlefinger has that Valerian steel
knife and I think that it is pretty
likely that uh Sansa will kill
Littlefinger with it sort of similar to
season seven but like the knife thing is
very much a show thing like the cosmic
significance of the knife so I don't
know where it's going I don't know what
they're gonna do with this knife in this
show
um well I've got some ideas
but uh yeah look we'll we'll wait and
see it's an open question what it's all
gonna mean with the prophecy and the
knife George says why did aemon beat the
messenger yeah so Daemon was with the
valerions waging this war against the
triarchy and then viserys uh sent a
letter saying hey Daemon I'm going to
send you some reinforcements to help you
win this war and Daemon when he found
out about the reinforcements started
beating the [ __ ] out of the messenger
bit of a weird thing to do huh and my
interpretation uh is that Daemon is
angry because he doesn't want viserys's
help to win this war he's fighting this
war because he's the second son he wants
to win glory for himself he wants to be
the one to do it just like a little
brother when a little brother refuses
their Big Brother's help because they
want to do it for themselves they want
to show their strength and their
independence
and I think that's what daemon's doing
this is also sort of borrowed from the
books um because in the books uh we're
told that when Daemon found out that uh
viserys was marrying Alison Hightower I
think uh viserys got really angry and
and beat the messenger within an inch of
his life hinge of his life is that the
phrase that's used yeah yeah yeah so
quote in the book
um
in the veil uh Prince Daemon reportedly
whipped the serving man who brought the
news to him within an inch of his life
when he found out that viserys was
marrying Alison and the reason why
Daemon was angry about that is because
if you know viserys has kids with Alison
that pushes viserys further down the
line of succession so now in the show
Alison has baby aegon and baby aegon is
ahead of Daemon in the line of
succession and they both supposedly are
behind rhaenyra the air but my point is
that you know Daemon attacking a
messenger is something that's borrowed
from the books
um yeah and in the books Daemon actually
did go to the veil because remember in
season one episode two
one at the end of House of the Dragon
episode 1 viserys told Daemon to go to
the veil because Daemon has a wife in
The Veil called Raya Royce
um and in the book Daemon actually did
go to the veil for a while but in this
case they just cut that
um and sent him right to the stepstones
after Dragonstone thanks for the Super
Chat from Kate Linton who says which one
of the valerion children are Dragon
Riders and how uh the Dragon Rider is
Lenor valarion who is the son of rainy
Targaryen and Corliss valerion and Lenor
is a dragon rider because his mother is
a Targaryen so Lenor has that blood of
the dragon that has the magical
capability of riding dragons
uh his sister Elena valarion uh also has
the blood of the dragon from rainey's
Targaryen so maybe Lena will also be
able to to become a dragon rider
potentially
thanks for the Super Chat from playful
cloud Who Says is there anything to read
into with Daemon and Rainier both openly
going against viserys and getting
covered in blood I mean it certainly
suggests that there is a similarity
between them doesn't it like they like
you know Daemon runs off and engages in
violence and has Adventure because he
feels angry and rejected by viserys and
in this episode Rainier does exactly the
same thing Rainier feels angry and
rejected by viserys so she goes off and
has a camping trip with Kristen Cole and
you know kills a pig and um so yeah like
I think we can see the Deep similarities
between rhaenyra and her uncle Ryan is
almost more similar to Daemon than she
is to viserys which of course is not
necessarily a good thing because Daemon
is such a violent shit-stirring unstable
individual so you know what what kind of
uh what kind of a politician will
rhaenyra be
thanks to the Super Chat from Edo who
says was it just me or was Alison's
belly extra large yes uh Alison has an
XL belly because she is pregnant I think
Alison is going to have a second child
by the looks of it I wonder who
Allison's second child will be I mean
that's assuming if she survives the
childbirth we know how dangerous
childbirth is in this world will Alison
survive but yeah I think Alison is
clearly pregnant here it's pretty nice
that Allison has all this stuff all
these midwives and wet nurses to look
after the baby for her that's pretty
good that'll be good thank you for the
Super Chat from Kaiser who says any
thoughts on Lionel since he wants a
marriage between the targaryens and
valerians but didn't support naming
corliss's wife as heir yeah well I think
that Lionel's logic is that he doesn't
want to support women inheriting the
throne uh but he does support valerions
and you know I think that
the basic idea that the valerions are
important and powerful and they have
dragons and you know they have a rival
sort of line to the throne with rhaenys
and her children like they are
potentially people who might want to
take the throne so you know marrying the
valerians does make a lot of sense
um I guess an interesting question is
that you know if if Lionel is supporting
um viserys marrying Lana
that would sort of displace Lenor
because like you know in the logic of
males inheriting first Lenor would
inherit the throne ahead of Lena if say
you know rainis was Queen or whatever
um so if viserys married Lena and had
kids then their kids would become
children but maybe Lenor would arguably
have a claim you know so that's that's
sort of the complication of this
inheritance stuff like that there is
there isn't always a super clear answer
to who is the heir and I think that if
viserys did marry Lena Lenor might be a
sort of a loose end there you know
um because every time you create a
marriage to try and seal a breach if you
have kids those kids might compete with
the claims of other kids you know
thanks for the Super Chat from SpongeBob
who says the valerion dragon rider was
cringe Daemon should have killed
everyone in the first scene we don't
need a battle in the third episode we
don't even know or care about the
characters I guess they could have done
more to introduce Lenor before he did
the thing like we did not get much
dialogue from the valerions like we just
had this scene where they were arguing
and they were in a bad situation
um Corliss and his brother vemond and
his son lanor and you know they're in a
difficult spot and so Daemon was the one
to go on the suicide run and do this
crazy thing to defeat them
um so yeah we didn't get a whole lot
from this war did we I mean I think it
you know I think it makes perfect sense
for lanor to participate in the battle
he's got a dragon he's got one of the
only dragons in the world I think it
makes perfect sense for him to be
involved and you know karaxi's we got we
got plenty of karaxi's action at the
start so I think that's fine thanks for
the Super Chat from alternate history
Hub who says any thoughts on Daemon
winning in open combat despite losing
the war for three years
yeah like what was he doing for the last
three years
I mean you know we get the sense that
basically it was slow and ugly I mean it
sounded like a bit of a stalemate you
know they were saying that the trayarchy
have just been hiding from the caves so
that they don't get roasted
um so that's why the part of why the war
has been so slow and these guys seem
sort of stuck on this island they're
talking about running out of food and
running out of Provisions so it seems as
though it's like dragged on for a while
um
so yeah it required drastic action to
try and change the status quo and uh
Daemon was the guy to do it thanks for
the Super Chat from Kalin and from Jake
Georgia R Martin complained the making
the eight scene prior to Bobby B's death
was his least favorite because the
king's Hunting Party should be grand do
you think he specifically requested the
scene this episode yeah well I mean
George Martin has reportedly you know I
mean like he was the co-creator of this
show he like worked out the the overall
story with Ryan Condell and um George
requested a few specific things
including brighter heraldry more
distinct dragons and also the inclusion
of joharis II
um the the Game of Thrones TV show just
like removed one of the Kings from the
Targaryen lineage the father of the Mad
King Aries is jeh Harris II in the books
but in the show they just cut out Jairus
and made aegon V the father of Eris
instead which sort of [ __ ] with the
story worry a bit
um so yeah it would not surprise me if
George specifically requested hey like
let's actually have a big proper Royal
hunt instead of the four Dudes walking
through the forest but again like that
was due to budgetary issues I think
thanks for the Super Chat from the pope
who wants a pug Theory video thanks for
the donation from Luke who says what do
you think about the white stag showing
itself to rhaenyra I think that it might
be what convinces Rainier that like hey
maybe I should be
um on the throne uh because you know the
white stag is the symbol of royalty it's
this almost like Supernatural
um portent showing that you know I've
been like chosen by God to be the heir
and you can see that she's really
impressed I mean it sort of is a little
reminiscent almost of you know Daenerys
in Game of Thrones when her dragons get
hatched and everyone's like holy [ __ ]
like she's got dragons she's legit she's
real she should be in charge like people
take a lot of like serious consideration
to these signs importance
um that's why this Royal hunt was going
after the white art in the first place
um because if they got the white heart
on the birthday of aegon I aegon
Targaryen The Baby then that would that
might convince people that hey maybe the
gods want aegon Targaryen to be the king
and the fact that they did not find the
white heart they just found a normal
deer
that suggests that maybe aegon shouldn't
be the heir and maybe rhaenyra should be
so I guess one of the open questions is
like you know is Rainier a dreamer
um in the way that viserys is like
viserys is clearly very uh influenced by
dreams and signs and portents and I
guess you know will rhaenyra be
similarly influenced by them what will
rhaenyra's relationship be with dreams
and prophecy will she be more like the
Sarah so will she not care about it
thanks for the Super Chat from papaya
who says is the implication here that
Lenor just claimed sea smoke during this
war out of necessity yeah so in the
books Lenor had his Dragon sea smoke
even back at the Council of harrenhal
when Leno was very young he heard his
Dragon sea smoke it was just a hatchling
at the time of the harrenhall council
but then he later became a dragon rider
in the show they just they haven't told
us um I guess it's I guess it's possible
that in the show it's like in the books
lanor always had seismo perhaps
we don't know they don't specify it but
hopefully we'll learn more about leanor
and sea smoke and their history and
their relationship soon I'm also very
keen to uh see the Red Queen meliss the
dragon of rainy staggerian
um I don't see why uh rhaenys and melis
didn't participate in this War I mean
rhaenys's husband Corliss was like in a
very dangerous situation this episode
like Corliss was saying oh I'm a little
bit worried that we're gonna be eaten by
crabs
um why doesn't Carlos's wife rainies
come and help her husband with her giant
fire breathing dragon like these things
are massive weapons of war and rhaenys
is like a pretty like badass woman who
is willing to get involved in uh
fisticuffs if she needs to so I mean I
it would make sense if rainey's
participated in this war but uh alas we
did not see her thanks for the Super
Chat from cloud Who Says the liquid in
the op could represent blood wax and or
wine to tie all the show's themes
together yeah that's a good point so
like the blood in the opening sequence
um you know it's it's the bloodline it's
life and death it's family
and you know we also make the comparison
to Wine the red wine which uh we we saw
a lot of from viserys as well this
episode and you're right like Wax like
the ceiling wax that they put on the
letters that they send with the Ravens
in Game of Thrones
um that ceiling wax is really important
we saw Otto sending a letter in the
previous episodes and you know there's
like the pink letter and there's all
sorts of you know who wrote this letter
and what does this letter mean aegon
received a very significant letter that
caused him to stop fighting a war in
Dawn so yeah I agree like ceiling waxing
letters is also a very uh relevant
symbol thanks for the Super Chat from
Kalin uh yeah lots of weird uh sexy
murals on the walls thanks for the Super
Chat from merciful who says Patty
considine's acting continues to Stun Me
Yeah well it's done George R Martin as
well George Martin said that the viserys
in House of the dragon has a tragic
Majesty that viserys in the books never
had so yeah George modern agrees with
you
and yeah I agree like he he loves his
kids he wants everyone to get along and
as a result he's sort of failing to make
hard decisions when he needs to his
downfall is that he's a good guy you
need to be a bit more of a [ __ ] you
need to be a bit more ruthless to be a
good King uh it seems thanks for the
Super Chat from Tom who says I love the
juxtaposition of the extravagance of the
camp and viserys not doing anything to
Rainier roughing it and coming back with
a true kill yeah while Rainier and
Daemon unlike viserys are willing to
piss people off are willing to do the
hard thing and are willing to do some
violence if they need to so maybe
rhaenyra and Daemon will be much more uh
you know capable of getting [ __ ] done as
politicians
um but uh you know there may also be
downsides to being divisive and violent
thanks for the Super Chat from Eternal
and Sam who says the grayscale will be
more than benign they made the choice to
show it on his raw skin in
um yeah well they did emphasize that
Daemon was covered in the diseased man's
plague blood so maybe that will lead
somewhere I mean like there's a
character called John connington in the
books who has grayscale and John
connington's grayscale leads him to be
more YOLO it leads him to take more
risks uh it leads him to
um
you know be more chaotic and to do some
extreme stuff
um so if Daemon got grayscale from the
crab feeder maybe Daemon would become
even more chaotic even more Fearless
even more suicidal because if the
grayscale is going to kill you anyway
you might as well go full YOLO uh thanks
for the Super Chat from glidus gliders
just released his video about House of
the Dragon episode two you all should
subscribe to Gladys uh Gladys has some
discussion videos with a notorious [ __ ]
poster called alt shrift x that you
might like to listen to so check out
gladys's channel uh glider says what do
you think the deer wanted from rhaenyra
did she perhaps have some crackers in
her pocket I don't know what deer eat
yeah I don't know I I think that um she
probably should have
um attacked the deer to weaken it so
that she could get it inside a Pokeball
um is one strategy she could have taken
because I mean that white deer is a
Shiny Pokemon right like that don't you
don't find those things easy it's a very
rare it's a very rare
um Pokemon so
uh you know if she if she had a dragon
and a white deer she would be the terror
of the realm thanks for Super Chat from
beckson and from Eugenio
who says bloodraven chose dayron over
Daemon the brother he loved because of
the currently show a song of Ice and
Fire Dream of aegon okay that's a
confusingly worded statement but um but
but the answer is yes so this whole
Targaryen prophecy stuff goes way back
and you know I mean
I I've said that I dislike
um aegon's dream being in House of the
dragon and I I don't dislike it for like
going against the book Canon because I
think it is very plausible that in the
books aegon did have that dream I mean
George Martin George Martin says so so
it is true it is Canon
um well I only dislike it being in the
show because I think that it makes it
too clear I like it when the prophecy is
more mysterious because in the books it
is very unclear what did bloodraven
believe about prophecy what did rhaegar
believe about prophecy and I think that
ambiguity is a lot of what makes it
interesting
um but you're asking about blood Raven
and dayron and Daemon so bloodraven who
is the three-eyed Crow three-eyed Raven
in the show uh the guy who teaches Brand
Magic this guy is bloodraven
and in the books he has a very long
history as a politician bloodraven was
hand of the king he basically ruled the
realm in the time of Duncan egg and
bloodraven was very uh insistent you
could say on keeping the blackfires off
the throne bloodraven uh supported one
claim over another
um and he opposed Daemon blackfyre in
favor of Deron Targaryen and a lot of
people speculate and and I think it is
probably true that part of why
bloodravens supported a particular
Targaryen bloodline was because he
believed that Targaryen bloodline was
the bloodline of the prince that was
promised it was the bloodline that would
defeat the white walkers there's all
sorts of stuff about like you know
bloodraven was hand for aerys the first
Targaryen
and Aries did not have children and I
wonder if maybe the reason why Aries did
not have children is because they
believed that his bloodline was not the
bloodline of the prince that was
promised it was my car's bloodline and
aegon eggs plot bloodline so like there
is a sense that like bloodraven and
rhaegar and aemon and aerys the first
had this belief that there was a
particular bloodline like joharis II
made uh Aries the Mad King marry his
sister rayella because a witch told him
that the prince that was promised would
be born of that line so like we are told
explicitly that a particular bloodline
is believed to be the one that will save
the world from the White Walkers and I
agree
um I I agree Eugenio that that may have
been what was motivating bloodraven in
his the sides that he took politically
in the black via Rebellion
um but it also is personal it always is
it always is personal as well as magical
and because bloodraven had a
relationship with uh Daemon blackfyre as
his rival and his enemy and they were
fighting over Shira sea star who was
their half-sister who they wanted to
bang
um so there's there's love and lust and
resentment and and human feelings as
well as prophecy and Magic just like in
House of the Dragon right now but um
yeah I I certainly agree I mean I think
the interesting question about this
whole aegon's prophecy thing is
you know rhaenyra knows about the
prophecy now but who will rhaenyra pass
the prophecy on to you know who
remembers uh after afterwards because
it's generation after generation and
there's this idea that rhaegar
rediscovered the prophecy in his papers
um you know maybe bloodraven even told
people in dreams about the prophecy like
the information is lost and refound and
reinterpreted over and over so um it'll
be interesting to see how this
information is passed on how it's
reinterpreted maybe the Dream Will mean
something different to rhaenyra to what
it means to viserys and aegon uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Mephistopheles
who says thoughts on Miguel sapochnik
departing the series
so Miguel sapochnick is uh the
co-show Runner of the show currently and
it's been reported that he's now going
to leave the show after season one
um and there's another veteran Game of
Thrones director who's going to come in
to replace him while uh Ryan Condell is
going to continue to be the uh sort of
main uh writer guy while Miguel was the
main sort of director guy
um and you know I'm not worried like it
sounded like Miguel was sort of dragged
Kicking and Screaming back to Game of
Thrones anyway I mean the dude put up
with like what what was it like three
consecutive weeks of nighttime filming
in [ __ ] Iceland or somewhere like he
has put up with some physically intense
shoots and being in charge of such a
huge stressful multi-million dollar
operation I think would be incredibly
taxing uh I I think uh I'm pretty sure
he had fewer gray hairs when he joined
on to Game of Thrones so yeah I do not
blame Miguel for wanting to be done with
it
um and yeah I don't know like hopefully
his replacement will be as good maybe
his replacement will be better I don't
know I don't you know I don't I don't
speculate on you know real life people
uh we'll see we'll see what happens
thanks for the Super Chat from eek who
says didn't Rainier assay that she
doesn't like the sound of pigs dying
since it reminds her of a crying child
but later she repeatedly stabs a boar
after wandering about her succession
I agree eek I think that um you know
rhaenyra said that squealing boars are
like squealing children so it might be
that rhaenyra was thinking about that
screaming child aegon her political
rival when she was stabbing the crap out
of that bacon boy the boar she she let
out all her anger on the boar and I
think that represents her anger towards
the baby aegon so uh yeah that uh
and and then earlier Otto suggested hey
we should marry rhaenyra to aegon so
what do you think rhaenyra would think
of that idea or maybe they'll grow up
and be great friends
remains to be seen thanks for the Super
Chat from uh Guillaume he says what do
you think about the Looney Tune like
bull that was that guy disappearing
after being torched by the worm yeah it
was almost like a slapstick moment when
that valerion Knight got stomped by
caraxis it was a little bit silly and
comedic but I mean I think it also told
us something about the characters like
Daemon doesn't really give a crap about
the triaki or the valerions really he's
just in it to prove himself win Glory
burn some dudes you know behead a crab
this kills the crab
um I think it was purposeful that Stomp
thanks for the Super Chat from Ryan who
says women have been on the throne
before Lenor wasn't Dragon riding during
that fight the amount of dragon legs
just a few of the inconsistencies I'm
not sure the show is staying that close
to the book I I when they say that a
woman hasn't set the throne before
they're not saying there has never been
a female bomb on this particular seat
that's not what they mean what they mean
is that there has never been a woman who
was the ruler of the Seven Kingdoms
before formally and that's true like
there never has been like yes for senior
and rhaenys sat in on the throne for
aegon and they issued pronouncements on
his behalf in the same way that a hand
of the king does like Ned sitting on the
throne and there has been a regent
Alyssa valarion
um who had power alongside Roger
Baratheon but it's true that there has
never been a female ruler ruling in her
own right in her own name as her own
rule before that is true
um uh Ryan says that Lena wasn't Dragon
riding in that scene uh he was we we saw
Leno go and woohoo after he was burning
everyone on his Dragon sea smoke yeah
there he is he said drakaris and
everything so yeah he he was there uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Rambo who
says could him losing a second finger be
a sign that he doesn't learn from his
mistakes yeah I maybe he if he cut off
that finger it would have stopped
rotting
thanks for the Super Chat from Johnny
who says I feel like by making both
reynera and Daemon so badass no one on
the audience is gonna support the greens
I mean Daemon is badass but like he's
not a good guy like he just beat the
[ __ ] out of this messenger for giving
him bad news he tried to kill the
messenger I I agree that Damon and
Rainier are badass but um I I think that
uh
he's he's still a dick but uh you know
there are there are going to be many
more developments and new characters
ahead so I I would not be uh issuing
pronouncements too soon on who the good
guys are
um there are going to be plenty more
developments and you know one of the
things that George and Ryan have talked
about is that this story they are aiming
to make it ambiguous who the good guys
are like there is no clear Heroes versus
Villains black versus white here it's a
little bit more complicated than that
thanks for the Super Chat from Jim who
says viserys serving himself from the
buffet pouring his own wine having no
one to talk to while being a drunk sad
boy and having the Stag captured for him
is he realizing how unking like he is I
think everyone is realizing how unking
like he is and that's why they're so
eager to figure out who the heir is you
know
um I think that one of the things about
viserys pouring his own wine like that
is that it emphasizes that viserys does
not have a cup Bearer his cup Bearer
used to be his daughter rhaenyra she was
the Royal Cup Bearer but she's off
reading books instead of being his cup
Bearer so that shows how rhaenyra has
left her role
um and has abandoned viserys it feels
like or maybe you know rhaenyra was
removed as cup Bearer maybe Allison
maybe Otto said that oh we shouldn't
have Rainier be the cup Bearer because
of XYZ we should totally have my cousin
you know hubish Hightower instead it um
but yeah I I think that visery is
pouring his own wine emphasizes Rainier
is absence
thanks for the Super Chat from Ryan who
says I don't normally disagree with
General consensus nor your opinion but
I've been so underwhelmed I even found
Lord of the Rings more entertaining that
crab feeder plot line felt like filler
fell flat on a crab-fed face I I I yeah
it is people who were expecting like
some long drawn out dramatic war with
crab feeder will be disappointed and
that's kind of part of the point is that
this whole war is like a dumb diversion
that Daemon joins in on for shits and
giggles and that's something that the
book talks about like in the book and
maybe we're gonna get that later but in
the book like viserys says that you know
I'm glad that Daemon is off fighting
this war I'm because it keeps him out of
trouble it's like this like funny irony
that he's like yeah it's a good thing
that he's fighting a war because
fighting a random war is like one of the
less annoying things that Daemon could
be doing right now it keeps him out of
trouble uh and viserys like funds the
war and supports the war basically
because he's glad that you know Daemon
is not causing trouble in his own house
so
yeah it's meant to be a diversion
um and you know like like pointless
horrible violence is one of the themes
of this story
um so you know if you're expecting
everything to be super rewarding and pay
off and feel glorious then uh you may be
disappointed well I guess that's part of
why they added the prophecy you know
like part of why they mentioned aegon's
prophecy is to say oh there is a meaning
behind all this violence there is
actually a higher purpose behind all of
this so maybe that's why they did that
thanks for the Super Chat from Heather
and from Joshua who says awesome episode
The Creative team had a heavy task and
they did it thanks for your amazing work
thank you Joshua glad you appreciate
very kind donation thank you thanks for
the donation from Judd who says are all
Lannisters in history bad has there ever
been a good Lannister yeah that's a good
question I think most of the Lannisters
are dicks I mean Titus Lannister the
father of Thailand was not a terrible
guy I mean
I guess he like sort of undermined his
house by you know hooking up with his
mistress and he was not a very good dad
but but Titus the father of Tywin was
not horrible I guess but yeah Thailand
is a mass murderer
um who orders his son's girlfriend to be
raped and Jaime defenestrates a child
and Cersei uh kills and torches and and
Tyrion is pretty evil in the later books
so um yeah Lannisters do tend to be
[ __ ] and maybe that's you know
maybe that's what too much money does to
you I mean the Lannisters we saw titos
in this episode he was so arrogant and
and just not a nice dude
um so much I think because of his his
wealth and his arrogance so maybe they
need to be taken down a peg or two and
maybe that's the point of tyrion's Ark
maybe Tyrion in the books will
ultimately become a better person
through his experiences I mean I guess
that's kind of what they did with Tyrion
in the Game of Thrones show I think that
Tyrion became a very boring character in
The Game of Thrones show later Seasons
but I think that what they were sort of
going for was that his experiences and
you know like believing in Daenerys it
sort of humbled him and it sort of
mellowed him out and it made him more
willing to sort of try and make peace
and try and make compromise uh though
that did fail catastrophically uh mad
duck machine says that Jason Lannister
was played by the same actor from the
original Game of Thrones show Hue of the
veil who died in the big tournament yes
that is true in season one episode four
we met Sir Hugh of the veil he went on a
joust and he got killed by the mountain
and then Ned's dark and barriston had a
conversation over his corpse so yeah
it's fun that we get to see Sir Hugh
return as uh Thailand Lannister and
Jason Lannister he's playing both of the
twins at the same time which is quite
funny Jason is the one with the longer
hair and Thailand is the one with the
shorter hair so that you can tell them
apart
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Peter
who says if only Rainier are killed the
white heart and brought it back to Camp
that yeah that's a great Point Peter if
Rainier like it was quite a uh badass
scene when like Rainier you know walked
back into town with this dead bore
um as a sort of a trophy which did sort
of impress everybody and turn some heads
which was cool but yeah I mean if she
had brought back the white heart yeah I
agree with you she might have actually
convinced some people that she should be
the head of the throne
um but you know I still think she
impressed some people
uh with her boar as well everyone gets
pulled pork for dinner Ryan said in the
inside the episode by the way I think
this guy is Harwin strong that's uh
Laura strong the club foot and I think
that is Harwin strong nicknamed
breakbones who is the eldest son of
Lionel strong and tarwin is the heir to
harrenhal and said to be the strongest
man in the realm I I would like it if
Harwin looked stronger
like does this guy look like the
strongest guy on the continent to you
guys he doesn't look especially strong
like no offense but I mean they could
have got someone super bulked up or
something maybe he should have worn like
a muscle suit under his costume
thanks for the Super Chat from Erica who
says do you think there is a connection
between the dragon Keepers costume and
Shepherds uh yeah I think that's a good
point Erica because yeah the dragon
keepers have these sort of long
sticks that they use to sort of direct
the dragons
um and they do look like a shepherd's
stick doesn't it
um and the valyrians uh did have
this history as being Shepherds
originally
um here they are the ancient valerians
like the precursors to the valyrians
were said to be Shepherds and so you can
see they here they've got the little
sticks which look quite similar to the
dragon keeper sticks so yeah I agree
that might be a deliberate connection
you know Shepherds of dragons
um of course with the valyrians there
are some deep law conspiracy theories
that you know they may not have actually
been the first dragon Riders because
there are some artifacts around the
world that seem to have been built by
Dragon Riders like the five forts unlike
the foundation of the Hightower that
seem to predate the valyrians so it
seems as though there were people before
the valyrians that had dragons and maybe
they were the Great Empire of the Dawn
maybe they were from a shy maybe all
sorts of stuff going on maybe the great
Empire of the Dawn created the valyrians
with blood magic all sorts of stuff
thanks for the Super Chat from Ashley
who says the white stag appeared to
rhaenyra but she didn't kill it whereas
Daemon had to do it through killing yeah
that's a good point I mean like Rainier
did have this violent moment when she
stabbed the boar to death very violently
and passionately
um but she spared the the deer the white
heart so I guess in this episode it's
showing us an example of rhaenyra being
violent and emotional and also an
example of rhaenyra being restrained and
peaceful
so I guess that leaves it you know it
shows us that she can do both she has
both peacefulness and violence inside
her whereas Daemon chooses violence I
think Daemon has never seen a problem
that he did not want to solve with his
sword and um so yeah that's an important
difference between them I suppose thanks
for the nation from Gideon who said why
did Daemon get so mad about the Raven
because Daemon did not want to Daemon
wanted to win the war himself he did not
want his big brother to win the war for
him he did not want viserys's
reinforcements he wanted to do it
himself
um and that you know it shows how just
emotional Daemon is he he wants
um he has these very particular
insecurities about you know not being
enough and not inheriting the power and
not being validated and not getting
attention and that's why he does the
things he does and you know I mean
there's also a political angle to it
because in this world you have to if you
want Power you have to show how cool and
Powerful you are you need Feats to
demonstrate your strength and your
wealth and your power and so you know
Daemon is advancing himself politically
by showing that he's powerful
thanks to the Super Chat from classiest
who says so the crab feeder had
grayscale yeah people people keep asking
this uh yes the the crab feeder heard
grayscale uh but it may have been the
non-contagious version of grayscale like
what Shireen had so it's possible that
Daemon won't catch it thanks for the
Super Chat from silverscale who says
viserys doesn't mean for Rainier to be
Heir if he meant it she'd sit on some
councils not be a show Pony yeah I agree
I think that viserys obviously should
try to include Rainier or more
um I think that viserys does want
rhaenyra to be Heir that's why he told
her about the dream and that's why he
had that giant ceremony telling everyone
that she was the heir I bet I think that
you know viserys does have doubts
um he does think that maybe his baby
aegon should be the heir instead because
he did have a dream about his son being
the head of the throne so I think that
viserys is sort of in two minds about it
um but I think he is serious about
Rainier or at least he was serious about
it um I wonder if you know maybe viserys
has invited rhaenyra to be a part of the
politics but she has refused you know
because she's grumpy or maybe Otto has
like pushed Rainier away I guess there's
a lot of questions about what that
Dynamic has been in the last few years
um because yeah Rainier really should be
a part of the politics more and in the
books they say that she was part of the
politics more but it's a difficult
Dynamic thanks for the Super Chat from
Keno who says I'm pretty sure Jason is
Jamie's grandfather uh no uh Jamie's
grandfather is Titus Lannister there's
quite a few more Lannisters in between
uh the current generation and Game of
Thrones thanks to the Super Chat from
Vesper who says speaking of eggs do you
think the size of the eggs on the show
makes sense given the size of the
Dragons I mean they're the same size as
an ostrich egg I mean we've seen what
the little hatchlings look like like
we've seen
um
we've seen drogon and rhaegar and
viserion when they were little baby
dragons and you know I I think like they
got all the wings and stuff they're
fairly large I think they look the right
size for the dragon eggs but one of the
things I always found funny about the
dragon eggs in Game of Thrones is that
they have scales
um which I I which seems silly to me I
think that the books do describe them as
having scales and the books also
describe the dragon eggs as being uh
colorful
um so like the color of the egg seems to
correspond with the color of the Dragon
Inside which is kind of cool
um and I also liked how in the previous
episode they mentioned that rhaenyra
chose and selected the dragon egg that
was given to the baby Balon so there's
sort of a tradition about who gets to
choose and you know the color and the
sort of symbolism it's it's all there
and it's going to be more important
um as The Story Goes On because there
are going to be more dragons and more
dragon eggs
thanks for the Super Chat from game who
said had aegon and Rainier married well
maybe they will thanks for the Super
Chat from Hamptons who says are there
any other targaryens in Westeros why
would anyone follow them if only three
family members were left
yeah so they are in sort of a vulnerable
position right now because there aren't
many targaryens around
um because you know Amon died Balon died
Alyssa died
um I mean there are some Targaryen
bastards running around like the
bastards of Sarah Targaryen in the East
[Music]
um
uh but yeah there are not a lot of
targaryens left and that does make them
vulnerable and that's why viserys
married Alison to make more targaryens
and that's why they're talking about
marrying rhaenyra to make more
targaryens I mean it is this delicate
thing where you want to have enough
targaryens so that you don't die out but
you don't want so many targaryens that
you have lots of competing claims
because if you have lots of targaryens
they're probably all going to want the
throne and they're going to fight each
other so it's a very delicate balance of
having enough targaryens
and at the same time they're usually
trying to only marry within the family
to try and keep the Dragon Blood
themselves
um and you know targaryens sometimes
have issues with like weird still births
and some sort of reproductive issues
with the Targaryen sometimes so it's a
delicate thing trying to have enough
targaryens but not too many thanks for
the donation from Ethan who says jumped
in love the content curious about your
thoughts on the Hightower motives also
the greasy black stone at the base of
the high tower and whether they have
Valyrian ancestry yeah it's an
interesting question so I mean Otto's
motivation you know Otto and Hobart
Hightower
um they want Alison uh and Allison's
they want Alison's children to be on the
throne they want to they want Otto to be
the grandparent of the king so that will
make the hightowers more powerful that
will give them a legacy that's what they
want but you bring up the Hightower
Foundation
because as I mentioned there is some
evidence uh that the
the valyrians were not the first
Dragon Riders and one of the pieces of
evidence is that the Hightower in Old
Town which is the city of the hightowers
uh the Hightower is built on this black
stone foundation and this this Stone
it's in the form of like a fortress it's
like this old building it's very ancient
building and the way that this
Foundation is made is with a dragon fire
because there's this particular way of
using dragon fire to melt and fuse Stone
so that you have these smooth uh Stone
shapes without any joins and without any
mortar it's all just fused together so
it's super strong and the interesting
thing about this black stone Hightower
Foundation is that it appears to be
fused Stone made with dragon fire but
the architecture is very distinctly not
Valerian
um it it seems as though a different
culture made this which is very weird
because it raises the question of like
well okay what culture had dragons years
before the targaryens like who were
these guys and one theory in the books
is that it was made by the goddamn
squishes there are these uh lovecraftian
fish monsters uh that that George just
took from H.P Lovecraft
um and some people believe that the
squishes were these guys were
responsible for building the black stone
there's also like a shy is made out of
Blackstone that's a place called yin
with like a toad Idol made out of black
stone
so there is evidence that like maybe
lovecraftian fish monsters built the
foundation of the high tower
um also this is located on a place
called battle Isle and there's this
mystery of like what what was the battle
that happened here and one of the
theories is that the previous long night
the previous battle against the White
Walkers may have been fought on Battle
Isle which is kind of terrifying because
it's at like the southernmost point in
Westeros
um and so yeah there are all sorts of
theories it seems as though there was a
dragon rider presence in Westeros in
like Old Town long before aegon the
Conqueror like like thousands of years
before
um and the hightowers are sort of
connected to that
um in the main Game of Thrones books at
the current time the Lord is Lord
Leighton Hightower and he's sort of a
mysterious guy who spends all of his
time
in his Tower reading Magic books and
someone says oh maybe he'll summon a
kraken from the deeps so it's it sort of
raises these questions of like you know
is he is late in a Hightower aware of
the squishes who built the Blackstone is
he aware of the ancient dragonlots and
also like in the books the hightowers
like the hightowers who have been
described in their appearance
have been blonde it sounds as though
hightowers are blonde
um which might suggest that they might
have like Valyrian Heritage maybe
they're related to the Dragon Riders who
are in Old Town and there's also like
the Danes house Dane
um has purple eyes and blonde hair at
least some of them do
um they almost look like valerians in
the books uh which is interesting
because they are not andols and they are
not valerians they are said to be first
men so like if we're trying to figure
out who were these Dragon Riders in the
South who built the Hightower Foundation
um maybe it was ancient dragon Riders
who are the ancestors of the Danes and
the ancestors of the hightowers
potentially Maybe
um and you know the the Danes have this
special unique magic sword forged from a
meteor called Dawn and there are
theories that it might be lightbringer
the sort of um the sword that defeated
the White Walkers and may do it again
we're getting we'll we'll get back to
topic but uh my point is that yes the
high towers are semi-connected to some
very mysterious ancient magic and
Prophecy in the world and it doesn't
seem as though Otto and Hobart are
particularly connected to Magic because
you know sort of the Paradox of Old Town
and the high Towers is that at the same
time that they are in a place that seems
magical they also are the homeland of
the maesters who are the secular
anti-magic people
um to some extent so it's sort of and
and they are the seat of the faith so
you know the high towers of Old Town
they're sort of balancing the influences
of like science and religion and magic
all at the same time which is a really
interesting complicated balance
thanks for the Super Chat from Ron Sands
who says do you think there's any
symbolism in viserys killing the Stag
and Robert's Rebellion ending the reign
of the targaryens
yeah I mean in in in the very beginning
of Game of Thrones we see a direwolf
that killed a stag
um
uh where how can I pull that image up
um there was a dead stack which which
definitely in the original Game of
Thrones show and books was a symbol of
uh a foreshadowing of Robert Baratheon
dying and the baratheon's falling for
sure
um I mean in this case I I don't think
this particular stag represents
baratheons anymore because the
baratheons are not super relevant right
now I think that the death of this tag
you could interpret as foreshadowing the
death of viserys I mean insofar as a
stag is a symbol of kingship especially
the white stag I think the death you
know that that deer is suffering as
viserys is suffering I mean it's
interesting like you know the the deer
is this proud Regal strong beautiful
animal that's all tied up and frustrated
and struggling which seems similar to me
to how viserys is feeling viserys is
this Dragon you know he is this Regal
animal
but he's frustrated and he's tied down
and he feels constricted and he doesn't
know what to do
um so I feel like there's almost a
similarity between the Stag and viserys
thanks for the Super Chat from band who
says it really looked like crab feeder
has grayscale yes uh but it might have
been the non-contagious version of
grayscale like Shireen had thanks for
the Super Chat from baragos who says
house valerion seems pretty cool and
strong what happened to them 200 years
later yeah it's a good question like
house valerion was so important uh but
in the time of Game of Thrones they are
not
um in the main Game of Thrones show
there are no valerion characters
um in the books there are a few like we
see the Lord
um of driftmark
um and he supports Stannis Baratheon
um and yeah they're not really all that
powerful anymore and I think one of the
main reasons why the valerians are not
powerful anymore in Game of Thrones is
because they were tied so closely to the
targaryens so when the targaryens went
down the valerions went down too
um it's not like Robert Baratheon would
want to be close friends with the people
who were close supporters of the
targaryens you know
but we may learn things in this show
about the downfall of the valerians
thanks for the Super Chat from Jake and
from old Hunter
um and from Olivia Who Loved Patty
concertine and from Jack who says quick
thought from the last q a
um
technology advancements yeah so we have
talked about how you know technology
seems to have gone backwards in Westeros
like the castles used to be huge and
Grand and now they're smaller
um but Jack points out that Jaime
notices uh that they've started building
round uh Towers
um because round Towers can deflect
catapult Stones better than better than
Square Towers
so yeah I mean I don't think Jamie says
how recent that that was that they
figured that out
um thanks for the donation from
smellsish and Jake who says it appears
the valerians and targaryens have
Bannerman lesser families sworn to them
what happened to these lesser families
after the war of the usurper
uh yeah I mean there are Lords in the
ground lands
which is the area around King's Landing
um and there's people like the the
rosby's and the stokeworths
um these are some of these folks
duskendale maidenpool these are some of
the places that are sworn to the
targaryens and some of them to the
valerians I don't know if the valerians
have any like large houses sworn to them
um there's also the uh the Celtic guards
of sharp point is it sharp point where
the Celtic guys are it is kind of funny
how the celtagars were uh left out of
this show because like in the previous
episode call us for larion said that the
valerians and the targaryens are the two
great Valyrian houses uh which is funny
because the celticars are also a
Valyrian house the celticars are also
from valyria like the valerians and the
targaryens it's just that they're
nowhere near as powerful as either of
those houses and they just get ignored
and I guess Corliss does not consider
them great he just considers the Celtic
guys okay and that's why they're not one
of the great houses and funnily enough
the celtagars have a crab as a Sigil as
their heraldry
so you know new Theory maybe crack ass
crab feeder was uh working for the
celticars all along hmm
thanks to the Super Chat from Antoine
who says that ambigua ambiguity around
prophecy works best I agree thanks for
the Super Chat from Shane and Baba Nero
who says did Jon Snow bond with rhaegar
in Game of Thrones well was he already
bonded with Daenerys yeah I mean John
did fly on rhaegar in Game of Thrones
didn't he
um they did not exactly have a close
relationship
um but there was a relationship uh yeah
here we are here's John riding Regal so
you know I don't know how much of a bond
they developed but John did ride rhaegar
um the green dragon
but uh yeah I think it's going to be
really interesting to learn more about
like human Dragon relationships in this
show like the viserys valerion one
especially I think is intriguing he's
dead dragon and I hope that we get to
learn more
thanks for the Super Chat from Maddie
who said there was a shot of the king
during the hunt that reminded me of that
sad clown painting I I don't know what
painting you're referring to thanks for
the Super Chat from Dustin who says
don't targaryens have a thing where they
don't get sick yeah the targaryens
believe that they have a thing where
they don't get sick but several
targaryens have died of the plague and
one Targaryen died of grayscale so they
are not completely immune not all of
them uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Nelly who says caraxis has no free will
why wasn't he helping are you saying why
wasn't karaxi's helping during this
battle with Daemon uh yeah I mean I I
think that if you wanted to be super
logical about it you would say that uh
Lenor on sea smoke and Daemon on
karaxi's and rhaenys on melis and
probably Rainier on Cyrax all should
have been there burning [ __ ] like why
would you not use all your dragons all
the time you know
um but yeah I mean
I I've always felt with all of the
battles with Dragons it's like why would
you even bring an army when there's a
dragon like I mean it was like that with
you know daenerys's Conquest in Game of
Thrones season 7 Game of Thrones season
eight why did Daenerys need an army why
did you just roast everyone with their
dragons I mean yes dragons can be shot
down with scorpion bolts and stuff but
um it always seems a bit silly to me
like so often they start the battle with
just the soldiers and then the tide is
turned when the dragon turns up you know
like Deus Ex Dragon every time which
feels a bit silly and repetitive I mean
it's just kind of hard to include
dragons in a fantasy story and not make
all of the non-dragons irrelevant which
is sort of one of the themes I mean
George Martin when he was originally
starting to write Game of Thrones in the
90s he originally considered not
including dragons he like Game of
Thrones was originally not gonna have
dragons in it but one of his friends
convinced him to include dragons in Game
of Thrones and Sir George dedicated the
first book to her if I remember rightly
so it almost didn't happen
thanks for the Super Chat from willing
to learn who says the aegon prophecy
thing is basically impossible to have
been passed down air to air given the
bloody Targaryen history because maegor
assured the throne and killed the heir
of anes yeah I agree that it's a bit
[ __ ]
um because yeah in episode one they told
us that the Targaryen Kings since aegon
they have passed down from King to King
the secret prophecy of aegon about the
white walkers but like there have only
been uh for Targaryen Kings before
viserys and most of them did not get
along with each other uh you know so
like maybe aegon told his son anes about
the dream maybe he also told his other
son maegor but thing and maybe Anis told
his son aegon uh who who died
um but thing is maegor the cruel
rebelled against Anis or didn't really
rebel against him he just sort of took
the throne after Anis died under
somewhat suspicious circumstances and
then may God sort of had Anisa's
children killed I mean he killed aegon
and sort of had the others killed in
various other ways and so my point is
that you know I don't think Amy's told a
told maegor the prophecy and I don't
think maegor told anyone any prophecies
it's possible that like Amy's told iria
and maybe Uria told joharis because like
joharis was much younger than Amy's so
it doesn't seem likely that Anis would
have told Joe Harris the prophecy so
like how did joharis know
um I mean we presume that viserys knew
from maybe his father Balon and maybe
Balon you from joharis or maybe Joe
Harris told Baylon maybe J Harris told
viserys after the council at harrenhal
my point is that I agree with you that
you know Targaryen history has been so
tumultuous and the succession has been
so unclear for most of the time that
this idea of the Kings passing down the
message I think it would have actually
been a lot more messy than that and it
would have gotten dangerously close to
people failing to pass it on I think and
my question is still like why does it
have to be a secret why don't they tell
all of the great Lords hey like there is
a big important danger that will come
from the north and we're gonna have to
be ready like make it a religious thing
almost make it like a sacred thing
um that the targaryens you know make
make the prophecy known like you don't
have to mention the white walkers
because people might not believe in
white walkers but tell everyone about
the prophecy thanks for the Super Chat
from Sophie B who says the clearly
included of the royna not only because
it was always the traditional styling of
the iron throne but also because they
kept removing it from the title from a
reason in Game of Thrones
yeah so the full title is like Lord of
the Seven Kingdoms protector of the
realm King of the Andals and the
rhoynara and the first man
um and I think the reason why they
didn't include the full title in the
Game of Thrones show sometimes was
because it's a bit too long
like you've got limited screen time you
don't want to spend half a minute every
scene doing the full titles so I'm not
mad that they don't do the full titles
every time uh but yeah it is curious
that they mentioned the roina at this
point given that Dawn and the Rhino are
not part of the realm yet thanks for the
Super Chat from Milo who says rhaenyra
marrying aegon uh would be great I agree
it could solve some problems thanks for
the Super Chat from Jose who says
thoughts on the armor in this show
compared to got I enjoy the armor I feel
like Daemon probably should have worn a
helmet when he was going on a suicide
mission against all of the arrows that
were being fired on him I mean the man
has a Valyrian steel helmet it says in
the behind the scenes that daemon's
helmet that we saw in episode 1 is made
of Valyrian steel if I was Daemon going
on a suicide mission against all these
arrows I think I would wear a helmet but
I guess the logic is that he wanted to
appear as though he was surrendering
so not wearing a helmet makes it seem
more convincing that he's surrendering
thanks for the Super Chat from Vada pili
who says Tywin would turn in his unborn
mother's womb watching this Lannister
guy talk to rhaenyra in the episode
uh I mean maybe Tywin wouldn't approve
of
um Jason's I don't know silly
braggadociousness but I think he would
approve of Jason's ambition I think if
Tai I think Tywin would do a similar
thing if he was in Jason's position
Tywin if there were still dragons in the
world at the time of tywin's life you
better believe Tywin would want one for
House Lannister thanks to the Super Chat
from Jesus and from Savannah who says if
I was targ and song of asked if I was
true I would intermarry with as many
families as I could so that the world
doesn't end in case of a strong spring
sickness
again like targaryens don't have total
immunity to sickness and you know if you
intermarried with every family you could
you might give the dragon writing Gene
to lots of people and if lots of people
could ride dragons you might end up with
a lot of uh destructive Wars right
thanks for the Super Chat from Jesus who
says probably not a good idea to name
the baby aegon it's not like the Lords
would look for any excuse to legitimize
aegon as the rifle Heir yeah so naming
baby aegon viserys and Allison's baby
aegon calling it aegon is obviously like
a big symbol of like this kid's gonna be
the king because the great founder of
the Dynasty is aegon Targaryen the first
um so yeah like viserys if viserys was
serious about Rainier being Heir he
should not have named his son aegon I
mean maybe it was probably Otto's idea
to name the kid aegon if we're being
honest I don't think vasera should have
accepted it but that's for Sarah's
problem he just lets people do what they
want want too much and it muddies the
succession
thanks to the Super Chat from ruler dos
and Reuben uh and Nelly who says yep
that Jason is Sir Hugh thanks for the
Super Chat from Dylan and Zerg
thanks for the Super Chat from Morgan
who says I'm enjoying the show my
biggest issue is the time jumping and
fast travel
uh yeah well the time jumping sort of
has to happen because this is like a a
historical show that takes place over
many years but the time jumping will
slow down
um they will presumably
um that they're gonna jump several times
uh in this season but I think after this
season the time jumping is gonna mostly
go away because like what we're
experiencing now is mostly like the
backstory and then we're gonna get to
like the meat and where most of the
stuff happens in quick succession
um that's going to start happening
around the end of the season is I think
the idea
um and fast travel I mean mostly we've
just been in King's Landing and um
Dragonstone which are very close
um and stepstones like it took them a
long time like it was years so yeah I
don't think that's fast traveling
happening thanks to the Super Chat from
Jake who commends Roman jawadi for his
soundtrack
thanks for the Super Chat from Daniel
and Reckless who says why didn't
rhaenyra kill the white heart I think it
shows her ability to show mercy and
peace but I agree like if she brought it
back it would have been a symbol of her
legitimacy thanks to the Super Chat from
Fernando who says was it just me or did
it seem like sea smoke just seemed to
change colors yeah I agree I think that
sea smoke might be sort of like dark
gray on like the top of the dragon and
then lighter gray on like the underside
of the Dragon see how like it's almost
white on the underside and the wings are
almost like red
yeah I I hope we get a better look at
Sea smoke later on thanks for the Super
Chat from Julius who says do you think
that uh certain greyjoys might make an
appearance I certainly hope so yeah like
people have been asking like are we
gonna see Starks are we going to see
Lannisters are we going to see greyjoys
and the answer is yes yes yes
um the show is mostly about targaryens
but we absolutely will see some other
familiar houses for sure
thanks for the Super Chat from Dan who
says was Strong's recommendation to look
closer to home a reference to Jamie's
song about Cersei in the Coldplay Game
of Thrones musical I have not seen the
Coldplay Game of Thrones musical so I
don't know thanks Daniel and Au who says
thanks for the entertainment thank you
Austin who says this app made me
painfully aware I was watching TV
everything was so bad
um sorry you had a bad time Austin
thanks for the donation from Sebastian
who says how many seasons will the show
last for uh the co-creators said that it
would be three or four seasons to cover
this story but they might cover other
historical periods later on thanks for
the Super Chat from aho who says will
noodle neck run in 2024 I would vote for
karaxi's personally thanks Daniel who
says is there a connection between the
Stags who were hunted and the baratheons
who took the Targaryen Throne I don't
think the Stags really represent the
baratheons right now because there are
no baratheons in in this episode but I
think that the Stags and the D is more
represent Kings in general like that's
what they said you know the white stag
is royalty
um so it is very interesting the viseris
sort of awkwardly butchered his Brown
Deer whereas rhaenyra seemed to have a
special peaceful moment with her
symbolic Shiny Pokemon white deer thanks
uh to Brian who says hot take rhaenyra
doesn't have a claim either the
Precedence of the harrenhall council
stands and they crown aegon or they or
if they go against it and the claim
belongs to rhaenys yeah I mean you can
make that argument like you can make the
argument that you know if rhaenys can
inherit the throne then rhaenys should
inherit the throne ahead of her
um but I mean there's different ways of
looking at it because like you can see
the harrenhall council as setting a rule
that there must always be a male ruler
and never a female ruler but you can
also see the council as being more
limited and simply meaning that viserys
was the most appropriate ruler at the
time
um some people push the narrative that
it set a male precedent but some people
don't
um but yeah I mean you can certainly
rainey's would feel very salty right now
and we saw a bit of that last episode
when rhaenys was like visibly frustrated
that you know they're talking about will
viserys's son be the heir or will
rhaenyra be the heir but no one is
talking about rhaenys being the heir
which sucks because she seems like a
pretty capable person and she's got a
pretty cool Red Dragon
thanks for the Super Chat from basically
a God who says what do you think about
Otto suggesting that rhaenyra marry
young aegon well I think that the the
Rivalry and the uncertainty between will
rhaenyra rule or will aegon rule you
could fix that by marrying aegon to
Rainier that would fix that problem
however you would then have the problem
of Lenor with a dragon uh and rhaenys
with the dragon and call this with a
giant Fleet and Lena with uh SAS uh
would be upset you would have this very
powerful Dragon riding family who would
be upset about not being included again
like callus feels so insulted by the
times rhaenys was rejected Lena was
rejected if uh rhaenyra rejects Lenor by
marrying aegon I think Corliss would be
very pissed but uh we'll have to see
what happens thanks with super chat from
wealthwolf who says I loved the scene
where rhaenyra complained to Sir crispy
Cole I hope they show how much common
people suffer from this internal family
struggle yeah I mean you know Jorah says
that when the high Lords play their Game
of Thrones it's the common people who
suffer and the common people don't care
who's on the throne they don't care
about issues of political legitimacy
they just care about their crops and
their Harvest and their personal safety
so I agree like I I want to see the
common person's perspective
um and I think that we probably will see
that as The Story Goes On
um we at least got a little bit from
that uh long-suffering Minstrel which
was quite funny Samwell the human iPod
thanks for the Super Chat from tulsey
who says Rainier walking back into Camp
reminded me of Legends of the Fall Jake
says if you are a minor Lord in this
world would you be which team would you
be on
well you know the the teams are still
forming so we'll discuss that when it
happens in the show thanks for the
donation from clyden who says do you
think the show might delve into some of
the high fantasy stuff like Valyrian
blood magic
um I think they might um there was some
interesting commentary from George RR
Martin in a video released by HBO
recently where he was talking about like
his philosophy of Magic In A Song of Ice
and Fire
um let me see if I can pull that up real
quick
um because there was a cool video
where George R Martin was basically
saying that yeah here we are
here's a quote from George R Martin
um so sometimes you know in some fantasy
stories there are magic systems where
there's a certain recipe and certain
words you say Expelliarmus and then the
thing happened but George Martin thinks
thinks that's boring when it's too
structured and predictable magic is
boring so George likes it being a bit
more complicated than that quote in
Magic it's not just the recipe or the
words of the spell it's who you are
who's doing it and what are you feeling
when you're doing it the valyrians while
practicing their blood magic and their
Fire magic noticed that it didn't matter
whether you pronounced the words of the
spell right whether you made the correct
sacrifice to the correct God all of that
may have some importance but one of the
big things was who you are and what was
your relation to the dragons
that's something that George Martin said
about magic recently in a house of the
Dragon promo video so I think that we we
can expect more magic stuff I mean
they've already revealed stuff about
inaugurion and the volcanoes were the
source of the power and so yeah I think
they are delving into that which is
curious like what role will magic play
in this story it's a good question
and it sort of fits the Fire and Blood
because Fire and Blood was written by
maesters who don't trust magic and so
maybe the maesters who wrote the history
book chose not to include the magic so I
think there is room for magic to be in
this show that wasn't in the book
um and I think it's really interesting
how he's emphasizing the connection
between uh Magic and Dragons because you
know in the time of the main Game of
Thrones show there are no dragons at
first in season one and there's like no
magic and the books talk about how that
now that daenerys's dragons have been
born magic seems to be returning to the
World Magic is stronger now the glass
candles are burning and the fire Mages
can do fire magic there's like this
Rising tide of the world is becoming
more magical because of the birth of
dragons and now in the time of House of
the Dragon there are dragons and there
are gonna be more and more dragons
pretty soon and so you would think that
the more dragons there are the more
magic there should there should be this
should be a magical time in Westeros so
it's going to be really interesting how
much of that we get to see in the show
um thanks for the Super Chat from takumi
and Samuel and non who says eggs could
only get so big without breaking much
like sauropod eggs they only get to half
a foot long and they were the largest
animals on land yeah I imagine that once
the egg gets really really big it's also
very difficult to lay the egg without
giving yourself great discomfort thanks
for the donation from tronsky loving
these breakdowns thanks for the Super
Chat from Sean who says if Emma had
Targaryen blood did she ever have a
dragon that's a good question
um yeah because Emma Aaron the mother of
rhaenyra and the dead wife of King
viserys uh her mother was dayella
Targaryen who was the daughter of King
joharis Targaryen so theoretically Emma
yeah maybe Emma could have ridden a
dragon
um I mean it's interesting that you know
Joe Harris and alisane they had nine
children who lived to adulthood but only
two of no three of them uh had dragons
aemon Balon and Alyssa I think I think
it was those three
um so not every Targaryen has a dragon
like lots of targaryens especially the
women don't ride dragons
um so it's like did they try to bond
with the dragon and fail or did they
just choose not to ride a dragon like
what was the deal we don't know
um and it'll be interesting to see that
in this show like who will and who won't
bond with dragons
uh thanks for the Super Chat from all
right who says why don't they just marry
the dragons if you love them so much
Mariam thank you Sean who says love this
channel how do you bring up these images
so fast uh uh practice and Magic thanks
for the Super Chat from David who says
can all Dragon Riders walk in fire in
the Game of Thrones TV show Daenerys
seems to be fireproof all the time in
the books Daenerys is not fireproof she
gets burned at one point
um and so in the books targaryens are
not immune to fire but in the TV show it
seems like some targaryens are immune to
fire
the show is not super clear like
Daenerys is but will targaryens in House
of the Dragon be immune to fire maybe I
suspect not because House of the dragon
is trying to be close to the books and
the books don't have the Fireproof
targaryens
thanks for the Super Chat from zero who
says uh how do you remember night King
one uh thanks for the Super Chat from
African sci-fi scholar who says it seems
like koraxi's felt Daemon get hit by an
arrow psychic connection yeah I uh yeah
we mentioned that that um when Daemon
got hit by an arrow caraxis seemed to
sort of scream in pain and yeah I think
that's similar to the Stark Warg
connection with their wolves I think
that's really cool and you know also it
almost seemed like Daemon might have
been using some kind of psychic
connection to control to to control
karaxi's better like raising karaxi's
Wing like I don't think it's all just
like the saddle or whatever like can the
dragon even feel like if there are
Reigns being pulled or anything I think
there may be a lot of magic involved in
Dragon control and I hope we learn more
uh and Scholar also says that uh brand
the Builder helped build the high tower
I mean there's a lot of Mythology about
brand Brandon the Builder like depending
on who you ask Brandon built the wall
and Storm's end and the high tower and a
bunch of other places it's not realistic
that one person could have done so much
so it's all ambiguous it's all uncertain
long lost history
thanks for the donation from Queens
queers land Australia who says sorry if
asked before uh Daemon had blood from
the crab feeder yeah I think that the
crab feeder's grayscale is
non-contagious like shireens uh thanks
to the Super Chat from Zachary who says
I need a [ __ ] in my life I agree a Clash
of Kings is a good book uh thank you
zuvet I agree Daemon has some plot armor
when he's running through those arrows
it seems a bit ridiculous to me I think
you blackfyre who says do you think the
crown viserys saw on his baby's head
were the knives that cut open Emma oh my
god blackfyre um yeah you might be right
um so you know uh viserys said that he
had a dream that he would have a son and
he said that he dreamed that that sun
would be born with a crown on his head
and Emma sort of laughed and you know
said that would be uncomfortable and
maybe you're right like maybe the metal
crown that visera saw in his dream was
actually the metal scalpel that Melos
used to cut open Emma and maybe viserys
threw the fog of dream just interpreted
that as he wanted to interpret it as a
crown
I think that's a cool idea
um and also you know all of viserys's
other details in his dream about like
thundering Hooves and smashing Shields
and Dragons roaring as one I think we
should we all should look out for other
examples of those things as The Story
Goes On because there may be many
different ways to interpret that
prophecy thanks Westeros and chill
thanks Zhao who says it's kind of silly
but I wish the dragons followed the
patterns of animals having
counter-shading lighter lighter colors
under and darker above ah why do animals
have lighter colors under and darker
colors above yeah I guess that is a
thing I wonder why thanks for the Super
Chat from Beats by Melisandre who says I
thought the first episode was flying
through plot but now we've had three
episodes that are nearly redundant yeah
it it slows down I mean I think you know
this is like a slow boil Rising tension
it's about establishing the
relationships
um if you want more action and violence
and stuff happening there will certainly
be a lot of that soon uh the pace will
pick up things will get uh look I mean
the book is called Fire and Blood and
there's going to be a lot of both but at
the moment it's really about setting the
relationships and the tension uh thanks
for the Super Chat from DM and sane who
points out the Pug uh how did Westeros
cross breed dogs enough to reach the
genetic Abomination that is a pug yeah I
mean I guess it takes some serious like
long-term animal husbandry to create
something as messed up as a pug but I
mean they have Bloody caraxis who looks
he's like the dragon equivalent of a pug
the person who designed him described
him as having a deviated septum and
being sort of physically strange I mean
the targaryens themselves are a bit sort
of uh you know I mean Matt Smith's
Habsburg chin looks like he might be the
product of generations of incest no
offense Matt Smith uh so yeah look yeah
I uh what what is the dog culture what
kind of dog breeds they got in Westeros
I don't know
um
thanks for the Super Chat from Andrew
and Nick uh and deep who says how do you
feel about the pacing yeah I think it'll
speed up thank you Arnie and himbo how
good of a dad is viserys I think
viserys's heart is in the right place
but I think he's making some shaky
decisions and thanks for the Super Chat
from uh Wiley who says you should check
out a video
um called George Martin on his favorite
Targaryen all right we're gonna wrap up
the stream uh thank you so much for all
participating before we wrap it up we
will just have a quick look see through
the uh preview of The Next Episode but
uh everybody thank you so much for
participating
um did you know that you can get a free
audiobook with an audible trial it's
true if you want the full story of Fire
and Blood in the world of Ice and Fire
and the whole house of the Dragon Story
you can listen to it on audiobook if you
go to audible.com ASX did you know it's
true you can audible.com ASX
and if you cancel the trial you still
get to keep the free book did you know
it's true
uh thank you all for participating uh
please subscribe and like and comment uh
and let's have a look at the preview of
The Next Episode so guys if you are not
wanting to see the preview of The Next
Episode we're going to watch that now so
you know potential small spoilers for
episode four we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it all right let's do it
um
so that's the Inside the episode Where's
the uh
where's the preview of The Next Episode
all right here we are let's look at the
preview
um all right so this actually is quite
interesting so we see Rainier Targaryen
with the catsport dagger Valyrian steel
dagger that kills the white walkers we
see some like Valyrian glyphs on the
knife which is pretty cool that only
seems to be visible when you put it in
fire which is exactly like the one ring
in The Lord of the Rings which is quite
funny
um and so she says from my blood come
the prince that was promised and the
prince that was promised AKA Azora High
AKA Yin tar AKA
um little peep um is the prophesied
figure who is expected to defeat the
White Walkers and some people think
Daenerys is the prince that was promised
or Jon Snow maybe it's Arya in Game of
Thrones season eight I don't know but
it's it is very interesting that they
are really explicitly exploring this uh
prophecy stuff uh there is a very old
old truth x video about Azor ahai about
this prophecy stuff I think that video
was a bit bad
compared to to the new ones but if
you're interested in Azor aha you could
go watch that
but yeah very interesting to see Rainier
engaging more with the prophecy what are
we going to learn what's going to be
revealed I almost hope that they don't
reveal too much but yeah I mean it's
going to be so interesting all these
questions about like you know since Arya
killed the white walkers is Arya the
prince that was promised
it's it's so weird it's a weird mishmash
of like show and book Canon
um yeah and he and his song will be the
Song of Ice and Fire is part of this
prophecy apparently and that's why Jon
Snow makes sense as the prince that was
promised because he is Stark ice and
Targaryen fire rhaegar and lyanna so you
know is this is this rainyro
foreshadowing Jon Snow being the hero
Maybe
um we see auto by the Iron Throne we see
Daemon with a haircut so I guess this is
years later we got Allison's in a nice
yellow nightgown balerions skull
uh the crown lots of talk about
succession is there some kind of
announcement that's going to happen here
that's very interesting yeah it looks
like some kind of announcement and then
we've got some dialogue from a street
performer who says like who's going to
be the heir will it be Daemon Targaryen
will it be baby aegon will it be uh the
daughter Rainier so it looks like the
uncertain succession continues to be an
issue in this episode I really like this
outfit that rhaenyra is wearing and
you'll notice that rhaenyra is now
wearing her Valyrian steel necklace
again
that's the necklace that Daemon gave to
rhaenyra and she took it off when she
went to confront Daemon at Dragonstone
and they were Rivals but now she's
wearing it again so maybe Rainier will
be closer to Daemon again
um thanks
uh for the Super Chat from Zachary who
says can we expect a Cocker Bridge there
is a podcast called Game of Thrones
Abridged by Alt shrift X
um I don't recommend it because that
person is just an absolute rap scallion
and uh you know it goes on silly
tangents all the time but if you want to
you can check out altshift x uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Ethan and
wealthwolf the pug that was promised
maybe the Pug is the prince that was
promised thanks for the Super Chat from
Sean who says did you like the episode
yeah I did like this episode I had fun I
this episode felt almost comedic to me
in a lot of ways like I don't know like
you know rhaenyra and Jason was comedic
and like the the human iPod Shuffle the
minstrel Sam was a very comedic moment
and like viserys like there was some
very real drama with viserys and his
emotional pain but it also was comical
the way viserys was so sick of all the
politics so I I found this to be quite a
funny episode personally and and the
ridiculous bombast of daemon's attack
and crab feeder so I found it
entertaining I found this to be a bit
lighter and simpler than the previous
um episodes
um and yet we we have been talking
continuously about it for
um for three and a half hours which is
why we're going to wrap up this live
stream very very shortly um so in the
preview of The Next Episode we see
Daemon Targaryen the Rogue Prince
wearing the crown of the stepstones they
named me the king of the narrow sea he
says so in classic Daemon fashion he has
decided to Crown himself as the king of
these like shitty irrelevant Islands
which is you know just funny and it's
[ __ ] stirring and it is a challenge to
viserys you know Daemon is calling
himself a king you know as like a rival
and his own power and I think I think
Daemon might be holding uh kragas crab
feeders Hammer there actually I think
that hammer is the hammer that crab
feeder used to nail people to the beach
I think so that's pretty cool
um so yeah Daemon is just like dripping
with trophies and swag and just being
cool it sort of reminds me of um in the
blackfyre rebellions there was King dare
on Targaryen versus uh Daemon blackfyre
and Daemon blackfyre was like the rebel
he wasn't really the rightful King but
he was very cool and he was a war area
and he had black fire and he was a cool
dude I think that the day the day Ron
Daemon rivalry is very similar to
viserys and Daemon
um so yeah it looks like the succession
continues to be complicated and it looks
like there's a courtship happening with
rhaenyra deciding who she wants to marry
because yeah in this episode vasera said
hey rhaenyra like you can choose like
like let me like help me out here tell
me who you want to marry and you can
marry him so it looks so as though there
might be a situation where rhaenyra gets
to meet some eligible bachelors you ever
see those like viral click bait YouTube
videos of Tinder in real life where
people just like see people like speed
date and just swipe left and right on
them in real life maybe uh maybe Rainier
is doing Tinder in real life in this
next episode that'll be fun uh I wonder
who she will choose
um so there continues to be tension
between Rainier and viserys uh a nice
shot of is that King's Landing or is
that somewhere else is that like Lana
sport or something that's an interesting
sort of coastal
scene landscape that we haven't seen
before the princeling is now three so it
looks like next episode is one year
after this episode and we hear about a
vile accusation discomforting news it
looks as though Otto might be spreading
nasty rumors about rhaenyra in the same
way that he spread nasty rumors about
daemon's air for a Day speech and yeah
rhaenyra talks about vile accusations so
what accusation has been made is it is
it an accusation against rhaenyra what
are these hands here doing is someone
having hanky-panky with somebody is
someone accusing someone of hanky-panky
we have some like Jesters with some big
hats for some goddamn reason maybe those
are the street performers
if I had to guess I would say that the
street performer in the voiceover who's
saying who's going to be the king
rhaenyra or Daemon or the baby maybe
that street performer had these like
clown Minstrel people maybe that was
part of the performance and maybe the
targaryens are angry about that
performance because it undermined
rhaenyra and like questioned the
succession and so maybe the targaryens
are punishing these street performers
for their performance a little bit like
Marillion and Joffrey in Game of Thrones
um who is responsible for this gossip I
will take out their eyes so someone's
made an accusation about uh hanky-panky
uh not in Rainier is nature to be
deceitful I cannot say the same about
your brother what deceit is Daemon up to
he's in a black hood so he must be up to
no good
um there's a bit of Fire magic going on
so yeah you know how I was saying how
like um in the books when daenerys's
dragons are born uh Fire magic becomes
more powerful in book two quaith talks
about it so yeah maybe me maybe this
here is an example of Fire magic that is
more powerful because of because of
dragons or maybe he's just using special
like flammable powders and stuff which
is also something that happens in the
books
um here's a rhaenyra running around in a
beanie
not sure what that's about someone's
drinking it looks like Rainier is having
a bit of teenage rebellion by the looks
of it Daemon in a hood up to no good
um Kristen and rhaenyra on a ship when
caraxis flies overhead maybe you know
that's Daemon returning to King's
Landing after his war and uh yeah you'll
see it all here on the old shift X live
stream in seven days uh we are doing a
live stream like this every week at uh
Sunday eastern time approximately
9 15 p.m or something
um what time is it we've got to end this
stream uh thank you so much for
participating everybody really enjoyed
it thank you so much for your super
chats I apologize if I missed some of
them uh thanks to the Super Chat from
amongst us law
um and uh if you would like a free
audiobook you can get it at audible.com
ASX like you can literally just like get
a free audiobook and then cancel the
trial and you get to keep the audiobook
you can get Dune for the second Dune
movie coming out uh crabs in the chat
pull one out for our boy Craig ass crab
feeder
um go and watch gladys's new YouTube
video the YouTube channel gliders watch
his Bliss takes
um and uh yeah look uh have fun be cool
um eat your veggies say hi to your mum
uh and we'll end it now like And
subscribe and uh you might like to
subscribe to the alt shift X podcast
there is a not shift X podcast there's
actually two World shift X podcasts
there's also a audio podcast and the
audio podcast is the audio from each old
shift x video so all of the explained
videos like the theory videos and stuff
we haven't put all of the videos up yet
but um all the recent alt shift x videos
if you would like to listen to them as
audio you can subscribe uh to the
podcast with your favorite podcast app
or on Spotify it also means you might
get notified better
um YouTube doesn't send notifications
sometimes so if you set notifications to
the alt shift X audio podcast on your
podcast app you uh may get notified and
you can also check out the podcast for
interviews and chats and things
um there's links in the chat to the
podcasts to the merch
um
thanks so much for participating and we
will have the house of the Dragon season
1 episode 3 explained video out on
Friday hopefully
uh
uh cheers thanks guys